Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. We have made you, O Adam, a creature neither of heaven nor earth, neither mortal nor immortal, in order that you may, as the free and proud shaper of your own being, fashion yourself in the form you may prefer. It will be in your power to descend to the lower brutish forms of life or you will be able through your own decision to rise again to the superior orders whose life is divine that is god talking to man in the oration of the dignity of man written in 1486 by the renaissance humanist giovanni pico
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。亚当啊，我们没有给你天国或尘世的属性，既非终有一死，也非长生不老，好让你能以自己意志的自由和骄傲的塑造者，将自己塑造成你所偏好的形态。你有能力堕落为生命中较低级的畜生，也能够通过你自己的决定，再次升华至神圣生活所属的高级秩序——这是文艺复兴时期的人文主义者乔瓦尼·皮科
della mirandola and it is also the way that the comic book writer Grant Morrison ends his book Supergods, a history of superheroes in which he says they represent our enduring thirst for the cosmic and the sacral. Now, who better, who better to discuss this subject in the very week the new Spider-Man film comes out than our very own Tom Holland, still for my money, one of the top two Tom Hollands. Dominic, that is so kind of you. So Tom, you took a tiny bit of, I mean, come on, we've mentioned the sacral, but you took a tiny bit of persuasion to do this subject because the existence of Tom Holland is a running sore, isn't it for you?
德拉·米兰多拉（Giovanni Pico della Mirandola）在1486年撰写的《论人的尊严》中，上帝对人类所说的话。这也是漫画编剧格兰特·莫里森（Grant Morrison）在其关于超级英雄历史的书《超神》（Supergods）结尾时使用的方法，他在书中表示，超级英雄代表了我们对宇宙和神圣永恒的渴望。好了，在新《蜘蛛侠》电影上映的这一周，还有谁——还有谁比我们敬爱的汤姆·霍兰德更适合来讨论这个话题呢？就我个人而言，他依然是两位最顶尖的汤姆·霍兰德之一。多米尼克，你太客气了。所以，汤姆，你花了一点点——我的意思是，拜局所赐，我们提到了神圣，但你其实花了一点点说服工作才肯做这个主题，因为汤姆·霍兰德的存在对你来说是一个长期隐痛，不是吗？
Well, I don't begrudge his existence, but I think that I suppose what makes it funny for people and people have been making jokes about it for at least, seems like an eternity, is I don't really know anything about superheroes. I mean, I know a bit because you've told me to read Grant Morrison's book and I realised reading it that occasionally I have stumbled across superheroes,
嗯，我并不嫉妒他的存在，但我想——大家觉得好笑的原因，而且人们至少在开玩笑——感觉就像过了好几个世纪一样——是我对超级英雄真的什么都不知道。我的意思是，我知道一点，因为你叫我去读格兰特·莫里森的书，我在阅读时意识到，我偶尔也会偶然撞见超级英雄，
but for some reason they've never, they were never part of my childhood particularly. And so, I mean, it's not an ideal way perhaps to start a podcast to say I don't really know anything about the subject. But you do. I think you know more than you think.
但出于某种原因，他们从来、从来都不是我童年的一部分。所以，我的意思是，一开场就说“我其实对这个主题一无所知”，也许并不是开启播客的理想方式。但你懂的。我觉得你知道的比你想象的要多。
Well, I agree. Because reading Grant Morrison's book, I realise actually I have come across him quite a lot. But, for instance, I've never read a superhero comic. All right. Well, prepare to be educated. I've never read one. Prepare to be educated.
嗯，我同意。因为读了格兰特·莫里森的书，我意识到实际上我经常遇到他。但是，举个例子，我从来没读过超级英雄漫画。好吧。那就准备好接受科普吧。我从来没读过。准备好接受科普吧。
But before you do that, before we do that, Tom, the great news of the week, which we haven't talked about yet, the big news is the amazing response to the launch of what I could see as the Avengers of the history world or the Justice League. Yeah, well, the X-Men are mutants, so I don't know what that's the comparison I'd go for. Oh, okay, I'm betraying my ignorance there. Which is the Rest is History Club, the launch of the Rest Is History Club.
但在你这么做之前，在我们这么做之前，汤姆，本周的重大好消息——我们还没谈过——最大的新闻就是对我们推出的、我视之为历史界的“复仇者联盟”或“正义联盟”的热烈反响。对，X战警都是变种人，所以我不知道这算什么比较。噢，好吧，我在这里暴露了自己的无知。也就是“历史的余烬俱乐部”（The Rest is History Club），“历史的余烬俱乐部”的成立。
So thank you so much to everybody who signed up. We're delighted to have you on board. To those of you who haven't signed up. Why? Why not? Well, there is that. But, of course, you'll still get your podcast as normal. Of course. Of course. And it is just six bands a month, but I promise not to mention that again.
所以非常感谢所有注册的听众。我们很高兴你们加入。对于那些还没有注册的。为什么？为什么不呢？嗯，确实如此。不过，当然，你还是会像往常一样收到你的播客。当然。当然。而且一个月只要六英镑，但我保证不会再提了。
But, Tom, the thing that I've really enjoyed is dipping into the Discord community. Yes, which sounds very superhero. Very superhero. Yeah, it's like Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. And it's rather startling because I would not have put you down as someone who was necessarily into dipping into things called the Discord. But it turns out to be your superpower. Yeah, you're really good at it. You've obviously been bitten by a radioactive ant or something. I have.
不过，汤姆，我真正喜欢的是浏览 Discord 社区。是的，听起来非常具有超级英雄风范。非常超级英雄风范。对，就像神盾局特工（Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.）。而且这相当令人吃惊，因为我原本不会认为你是那种会对泡在一个叫 Discord 的地方感兴趣的人。但事实证明，这是你的超能力。对，你真的很擅长这个。你显然是被一只放射性蚂蚁咬过什么的。我是。
So in the Discord community, you know, they have a whole thread of people in the Restless History Club who are from the Midlands, a Mercian community. And from East Anglia, I see. You made a very rude joke about mine. Well, there was one guy who went on, he said, is there anyone here from East Anglia? I see. There's an East Anglia one. Which you made a very rude joke about, Mike. Well, there was one guy who went on, he said, is there anyone here from East Anglia?
所以在 Discord 社区里，你知道的，他们有一整串来自“历史的余烬俱乐部”、来自米德尔兰兹（Midlands）的麦西亚（Mercian）社区的人。还有来自东安格利亚（East Anglia）的，我懂了。你对我的那个开了一个非常粗鲁的玩笑。嗯，当时有一个家伙上线，他说：“这里有来自东安格利亚的人吗？”我懂了。有一个东安格利亚的专区。你对它开了个非常粗鲁的玩笑，迈克。嗯，当时有一个家伙上线，他说：“这里有来自东安格利亚的人吗？”
And I said, well, if you've listened to our CIA podcast, you'll know that Liam Neeson will be along in a minute. Yes, very funny. So it's piled into me, my inability to do a Liam Neeson accent and the fact, ha, ha, ha, ha, that I share the name with the actor who plays Spider-Man. Yeah, we should mention, we've got bonus episodes coming up. Oh, yes.
然后我说：“嗯，如果你听过我们的中情局（CIA）播客，你就会知道连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）一会儿就会来。”是的，非常搞笑。所以大家都来取笑我，笑我模仿不了连姆·尼森的口音，还有哈哈哈哈，我居然和扮演蜘蛛侠的演员同名。对，我们应该提一下，我们有加更节目要推出。噢，是的。
Sorry. For our members. So the bonus episodes will be out every week. And this week, so Wednesday, the 15th of December at 8pm. 8 o'clock British time. We're doing our first live streamed show for Restless History Club members, which is all about the 1960s. Looking forward to that? I certainly am.
抱歉。为了我们的会员。所以加更节目将每周播出。本周——也就是12月15日星期三晚上8点。英国时间8点。我们将为“历史的余烬俱乐部”会员举办首场直播节目，主题全部关于20世纪60年代。期待吗？我当然期待。
It's a great topic. It's a topic we're both very much interested in you know a lot more about than i do but i i have views yeah i know you have which i know you'll you'll look forward to hearing so if you if you can't make it and you're a restless history club member you will get a chance to um access it afterwards don't worry if you're not a restless history club member well you won't but i mean but you can sign sign up between now and Wednesday and then you get to hear it. Where would you sign up, Tom? You'd go to restlesshistorypod.com.
这是一个很棒的话题。这是一个我们俩都非常感兴趣的话题，你知道的也比我多得多，但我——我也有看法。对，我知道你有，我知道大家会很期待听到。所以如果你无法出席，而你又是“历史的余烬俱乐部”会员，你将有机会——嗯——事后观看回放，别担心。如果你不是“历史的余烬俱乐部”会员，嗯，你就看不了，不过我的意思是——但你可以在现在到周三之间注册，然后你就能听到了。你在哪里注册呢，汤姆？你会去 restlesshistorypod.com。
Very good. All right. Enough of the club promotion. Let's talk about superheroes. Do you have a question? I think you have a question that you'd like to ask. I do. It's from SO3Klauswitz, who put it on the Discord.
很好。好了。俱乐部宣传就到这里。我们来聊聊超级英雄。你有一个问题吗？我想你有一个很想问的问题。我有。这是来自 SO3Klauswitz 的问题，他发在 Discord 上的。
He did. And he asked, what caused the sudden rise of superhero stories in the mid-20th century? And that's an absolutely banging question with which to kick the show off. So my answer to that would be it's kind of, there's a kind of sort of almost like a boring logistical reason, which is that in 1933, you have the launch of comic books. So a man called Max Gaines, he, I can't remember what it's called, Something Funnies.
他确实发了。他问，是什么导致了20世纪中期超级英雄故事的突然崛起？这是一个绝对精彩绝伦的问题，用来开启今天的节目再合适不过了。所以我的回答是，这有点——有一种几乎像无聊的后勤原因，那就是在1933年，漫画书诞生了。所以一个叫马克斯·盖恩斯（Max Gaines）的人，他——我不记得它叫什么了，“趣味漫画”（Something Funnies）。
It's the first sort of comic book. It's a way of using the printing presses. It's cheap. Initially, they're reproducing cartoon strips from- It's apparently a four-colour printing process. Yeah. So it's very simple. So it enables that kind of bright-
这是第一种类似漫画书的东西。这是一种利用印刷机的方法。它很便宜。最初，他们是在翻印——这显然是一种四色印刷工艺。对。所以非常简单。所以它促成了那种明亮——
Exactly. The lurid colours that we- The lurid colours. So it's, I mean So it enables that kind of bright. Exactly. The lurid colors. The lurid colors. So we keep coming to this, that it's kind of technological innovations that then precipitate cultural processes of change. But obviously there are cultural roots to the superhero, aren't there? Longer roots. Well, yeah. We've had a lot of questions about that. So Pederda4 on Twitter, did romans think of mythical heroes the same way
没错。我们所经历的那些艳丽的色彩——艳丽的色彩。所以——所以它促成了那种明亮。没错。艳丽的色彩。艳丽的色彩。所以我们不断回到这一点，即这是一种技术创新，进而催生了文化变革的过程。但显然超级英雄是有文化根源的，对吧？更深厚的根源。嗯，是的。我们收到了很多关于这方面的问题。所以 Twitter 上的 Pederda4 问，古罗马人对神话英雄的看法是否与——
um diego morgado are superheroes of modern mythology henry midgley do you think there's any genealogical link between the modern concept of superheroes and the greek hero have we modernized hercules and made him spider-man has him i mean is modern superheroes morality and reluctance to take human life a symbol of christian morality in contrast to the norse sagas or all right so grant mor Morrison putting it in his book, basically all in the context of ancient mythology. He says super gods, he sees them as, he has that thing about the quote from Giovanni Pico della Mirandola about sort of man caught between the kind of base and the divine and this sort of humanistic kind of reaching for something beyond and all this
嗯，迭戈·莫加多（Diego Morgado）问，超级英雄是现代神话吗？亨利·米德利（Henry Midgley）问，你认为现代超级英雄的概念与希腊英雄之间有什么血缘关系吗？我们将赫拉克勒斯（Hercules）现代化并将他变成了蜘蛛侠吗？我的意思是，现代超级英雄的道德感以及对夺去人命的抗拒，是否是基督教道德的象征，与北欧萨加史诗形成鲜明对比？或者——好吧，所以格兰特·莫里森在他的书中将其归结为：基本上全部置于古代神话的语境中。他说“超 gods（超神）”，他将他们视作——他引用了乔瓦尼·皮科·德拉·米兰多拉关于人类处于卑微与神圣之间的一种状态的话，这种介于卑微与神圣之间的人文主义对某种超越之物的追寻，以及所有这些
kind of stuff now you i know that you don't really buy all that do you amazingly for once you don't see them as christian i don't i don't really think it's anything to do with christianity and you don't it's anything to do with greek myth or norse myth or anything anything like that but okay let me get the counter argument though tom uh which you need to dispel is um you've got thor you've got a lot of sort of greek and roman influences so captain marvel when captain marvel is created he's one of the the first sort of superheroes in the 1940s or whatever and um there's a sort of he gets his powers from solomon hercules, Atlas, Zeus, Achilles and Mercury, which is Shazam. Shazam. Exactly. Right.
诸如此类的事情。现在，我知道你其实并不买账，对吧？令人惊讶的是，你破天荒地没有把他们视为基督教的产物。我不——我真的不认为这跟基督教有什么关系，你也不认为这跟希腊神话、北欧神话或诸如此类的东西有任何关系。但是，好吧，让我提出反驳观点吧，汤姆——你需要消除这种观点——嗯，你有雷神（Thor），你有很多希腊和罗马的影响。所以惊奇队长（Captain Marvel）在被创造出来时，他是20世纪40年代左右最早的超级英雄之一，然后——他的力量来自所罗门、赫拉克勒斯、阿特拉斯、宙斯、阿喀琉斯和墨丘利，也就是沙赞（Shazam）。沙赞。没错。对。
I mean, is that link not obvious there? Or do you think that's just complete window dressing and it's utterly contrived? Older listeners may remember that in the 70s there was a TV show called Mr. Ben. And the plot of Mr. Ben was that Mr. Ben wore a bowler hat. He'd walk along the street. He'd go into a fancy dress shop and the shopkeeper would magically appear and lend him a fancy dress outfit. And it might be a Roman soldier or a caveman or a cowboy or whatever. And Mr. Ben would go into the changing room and he'd put this outfit on. And then he enter a kind of magical world where you know if he put on the caveman show there'd be dinosaurs if you put the romans on he'd be you know an ancient rome or whatever so it would go on
我的意思是，这种联系难道不是很明显吗？还是说你认为这完全只是表面功夫，而且是极其牵强的？年纪大一点的听众可能会记得，在70年代有一个叫《本先生》（Mr. Ben）的电视节目。这个节目的情节是，本先生戴着一顶礼帽。他在街上走着。他走进一家化装舞会店，店主会神奇地出现，借给他一套化装服。可能是一个罗马士兵、一个原始人、一个牛仔或其他什么。然后本先生会走进更衣室，穿上这套衣服。接着他会进入一个神奇的世界，你知道的，如果他穿上原始人的服装，就会有恐龙；如果他穿上罗马人的服装，他就会身处古罗马等等，就这样一直进行下去。
i mean i think that basically that's the level that superheroes operate on um these are essentially it seems to me vigilante figures yeah they're bred of the very specific circumstances of kind of american history which will come towards social history attitudes towards policing um attitudes towards uh the individual um picking up arms to defend the american way of life and basically these are people who are cosplaying they are characters that that may well, you know, you may well get Thor, you may well get Wonder Woman drawing on the Amazons or whatever. But, you know, we're not in the level,
我的意思是，我认为这基本上就是超级英雄运作的层面——在我看来，这些本质上是治安维持者形象，对吧？它们孕育自美国历史非常具体的环境，我们稍后会谈到社会历史、对治安管理的态度、对——个人的态度、拿起武器捍卫美国生活方式的态度。基本上，这些人是在进行角色扮演（cosplay），他们是这样的角色——你很可能会看到雷神，你很可能会看到取材于亚马逊人或什么的的神奇女侠。但是，你知道的，我们不在这个层面上——
say, of Tolkien with his fantasy. Yeah. Clearly drawing on a deep knowledge of ancient literature, ancient myth, Christian myth, whatever, to amplify his world. None of these characters seem really to have any interest in that. I mean, it's about fights. It's about costumes. And that's basically whether it's, you know, the most basic kind of wham-bam kind of Adam West type Batman cartoon shows where it's played for laughs in its camp or the kind of the Watchmen, the dark, the somber, the kind of Finnegan's Wake version of comic book.
比方说，托尔金（Tolkien）的奇幻作品。是的。显然汲取了对古代文学、古代神话、基督教神话等深厚的知识，来放大他的世界。这些角色中似乎没有一个真正对这些感兴趣。我的意思是，这是关于打斗的。这是关于服装的。这基本上就是——无论是那种最基础的、砰砰作响的亚当·韦斯特（Adam West）式的蝙蝠侠动画片（里面带有戏谑和坎普风格），还是那种《守望者》（Watchmen）、黑暗的、阴郁的、某种乔伊斯《芬尼根守灵记》（Finnegan's Wake）风格的漫画书版本。
They're still not really interested in any of these kind of mythic antecedents. They're interested in America. Yeah. 20th century America. But hold on. Okay. They're interested in any of these kind of mythic antecedents. They're interested in America, 20th century America. But hold on. Okay, they're interested in 20th century. They're born in 20th century America, and particularly in the 1930s, and we'll come to that in a second. But, for example, Ian B., who's one of our Athelstan members of the Rest is History Club,
他们其实仍然对所有这些神话前身不感兴趣。他们感兴趣的是美国。是的。20世纪的美国。等等。好吧。他们对所有这些神话前身感兴趣。他们感兴趣的是美国，20世纪的美国。等等。好吧，他们对20世纪感兴趣。他们诞生于20世纪的美国，特别是在20世纪30年代，我们一会儿会谈到这一点。但是，例如，伊恩·B（Ian B.），他是我们“历史的余烬俱乐部”的埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）级别的会员之一，
he asked a question on the Discord chat, and he says there's a compelling argument that Sherlock Holmes is the original superhero. Do you you agree or he asks about other figures from history who lay the groundwork achilles alexander king arthur robin hood i would say um there is some slight lineage some very faint lineage from robin hood the folk hero he a mask. Who wears a mask and has a hideout and has sidekicks. Yeah. I think Sherlock Holmes, Tom. We talked about Sherlock Holmes as a superhero in our last,
他在 Discord 聊天室里提了一个问题，他说有一个令人信服的论点，即夏洛克·福尔摩斯是最初的超级英雄。你同意吗？或者他问起历史上其他为超级英雄奠定基础的人物：阿喀琉斯、亚历山大、亚瑟王、罗宾汉。我会说——罗宾汉这位民间英雄带来了一些微弱的血缘关系，他戴着面具，有一个藏身处，还有助手。是的。我认为夏洛克·福尔摩斯，汤姆。我们在上一期中讨论过夏洛克·福尔摩斯是一位超级英雄，
in our Sherlock Holmes podcast. Well, we know that. And I know that from having read Grant Morrison's book, that the guys who invent Batman say that he has the athleticism of D'Artagnan. So one of the, you know, confusingly, he's the fourth musketeer in the three musketeers. Yes. And the brainpower of Sherlock Holmes.
在我们的夏洛克·福尔摩斯播客中。嗯，我们知道这一点。而且我知道，从读过格兰特·莫里森的书来看，创造蝙蝠侠的那些家伙说，他拥有达达尼昂（D'Artagnan）的运动能力——也就是，你知道的，令人困惑的是，他是《三剑客》中的第四个火枪手。是的。以及夏洛克·福尔摩斯的智商。
Yeah. So that's a conscious, absolutely kind of. Sherlock Holmes is definitely in the air when they're writing these things. Well, and what I'd also say is that, I mean, we talked about this on the Sherlock Holmes episode, that London is a character in Sherlock Holmes. In a sense, people's understanding of London is still shaped by that. And I would say that Batman's Gotham City has an analogous role.
是的。所以这是一个有意识的、绝对的——当他们在创作这些东西时，夏洛克·福尔摩斯显然弥漫在空气中。嗯，我还要说的是，我的意思是，我们在夏洛克·福尔摩斯那一集里讨论过，伦敦是夏洛克·福尔摩斯故事中的一个角色。从某种意义上说，人们对伦敦的理解仍然由其塑造。我要说的是，蝙蝠侠的哥谭市（Gotham City）也有类似的作用。
People call New York Gotham, don't they? I mean, they use the words almost interchangeably. But right the way through, you know, all the way that Batman's being portrayed, New York Gotham is a character in the way that London is a character in the Shilkheim story. I think that's very true. I think that's absolutely right. But I think there are two other characters, actually,
人们把纽约叫作哥谭，不是吗？我的意思是，他们几乎可以互换使用这两个词。但一直以来，你知道的，在蝙蝠侠被塑造的过程中，纽约哥谭就像伦敦在夏洛克·福尔摩斯故事中一样，是一个角色。我认为这非常真实。我认为这绝对正确。但我认为还有另外两个角色，实际上，
that are worth mentioning that are definitely there when the superhero creators are working in the late 1930s. One of them, very unexpected actually to some listeners, is the Scarlet Pimpernel. And actually lots of comic book historians say the Scarlet Pimpernel is massive. Yeah, tell us about that. Yeah, the Scarlet Pimpernel is created initially in a play
值得一提的是，当超级英雄创作者在20世纪30年代末工作时，它们绝对是在场的。其中一个对某些听众来说非常出乎意料，那就是《红花侠》（The Scarlet Pimpernel）。实际上，许多漫画史学家都说《红花侠》影响巨大。是的，给我们讲讲这个。是的，《红花侠》最初是奥克西男爵夫人（Baroness Orczy）于1903年创作的一部戏剧，随后在1905年出版了书。所以《红花侠》以法国大革命为背景。他去拯救——他戴着面具，极其英勇潇洒，就像一个火枪手。他把法国贵族从断头台上救下来。但有趣的是，是什么让他明显成为后来角色（如克拉克·肯特、彼得·帕克等）的前身呢？那就是他拥有双重身份。
by Baroness Orksy in 1903 and then the book in 1905. So the Scarlet Pimpernel is set in the French Revolution. He rescues, he's masked, he's incredibly swashbuckling, he's like a musketeer. He rescues French aristocrats from the guillotine. But the interesting thing there and what makes him clearly an antecedent of later characters, Clark Kent and Peter Parker and so on, is that he has a dual identity.
所以一个是红花侠，也就是超级英雄；另一个是一个软弱、脂粉气的纨绔子弟，名叫珀西·布莱克尼爵士（Sir Percy Blakeney）。他刻意扮演这个角色，就像布鲁斯·韦恩（Bruce Wayne）或克拉克·肯特（Clark Kent）那样。他装作一个软弱无能的人，以此向法国人掩盖他的真实身份。我认为大多数漫画史学家都会说，《红花侠》在20世纪10年代和20年代的文化中有着巨大的影响力。他们所有人都应该知道这一点。另一个或许部分启发了他的角色就是佐罗（Zorro）。
So one is the Scarlet Pimpernel, the superhero, and the other is this foppish, effeminate weed called Sir Percy Blakeney. And he plays up to that part, just like Bruce Wayne does, or just like Clark Kent does. He plays the weed to disguise the French about his real identity. And I think most comic book historians say Scarlet Pimpernel is huge in the culture of the 1910s and 1920s. They would all have been aware of it. And the other character who he perhaps partly inspires is Zorro.
是的，他也戴着面具。是的。而且我们——我的意思是，在我们成长过程中，佐罗对我们来说非常熟悉，我想是的。但我认为他现在有点被遗忘了，不是吗？你觉得现在的孩子知道佐罗是谁吗？有一部电影，不是吗？最近有一部电影。是的，但那是25年前的事了。
Yes, he was also masked. Yeah. And we, I mean, Zorro was very familiar to us, I would imagine, when we grew up. But I think he's kind of forgotten now, isn't he? Do you think kids now know who Zorro is? There was a film, wasn't there? There was a film recently. Yeah, but that's 25 years ago.
是的。对我们来说这似乎很近。是的，我同意。对我们来说这似乎很近。是的，我同意。是的。所以他是同一类人。现在，他确实是一个在1919年被创造出来的蒙面治安维持者。他有着双重身份。所以他是唐迭戈·德拉·维加（Don Diego de la Vega），但他也是佐罗。
Yeah. Which seems recent to us. Yeah, I agree Havago. Which seems recent to us. Yeah, I agree. Yes. So he's the same thing. Now, he really is a masked vigilante that he's created in 1919. He has that dual identity. So he's Don Diego de la Vega, but he's also Zorro.
他身上有“Z”字符号，他用剑把它刻在各种东西上，这很像蝙蝠标志之类的东西。所以我认为他们在30年代显然存在于空气中。但还有——超级大反派。所以我想说的是，菲托玛斯（Fantomas），这个经常出没于巴黎的超级罪犯，就像小丑（Joker）和小企鹅（Penguin）出没于哥谭市一样。傅满洲（Fu Manchu），我猜。傅满洲，绝对是。
He has the Z symbol that he kind of carves into things and stuff with his sword, which is very sort of like the bat symbol or whatever. So I think they're clearly in the ether in the 30s. But also, I mean, supervillains. So I would say Fantomas, this super criminal who haunts Paris, rather in the way that the Joker and Penguin come to haunt Gotham City. Fu Manchu, I suppose. Fu Manchu, absolutely.
这就是——我猜——邦德和超级英雄之间的交汇点，就是全球阴谋的概念。是的。但与邦德那些无论多么巴洛克式地扎根于当代地缘政治的故事不同——我知道超人和蝙蝠侠在战争中确实与希特勒对抗——本质上，反派们与当代政治完全是抽象脱节的。是的，确实如此。
And this is the kind of intersection point between, I guess, kind of Bond and superheroes is this idea of global conspiracies. Yes. But whereas the Bond ones are, however, Baroque-ly kind of grounded in contemporary geopolitics. And I know that Superman and Batman do take on Hitler in the war. Essentially, the villains are completely abstracted from contemporary politics. Yeah, they are.
不过我知道，起初超人其实更接地气一点，我会这么说。嗯，这来自主流——我的意思是，在更新的作品中，我知道它更扎根于现实。但我认为——你知道的，通过40、50、60年代，这些——我的意思是，这不是——嗯，这是给小孩子们看的。好吧，让我们从超人开始，因为超人是第一个正统的超级英雄，不是吗？我想是的。他诞生于1938年，1938年中期。是什么让他成为这类故事总体上的代表？就像许多这样的超级英雄一样，他们是由犹太籍作家和插画家创造的，这些人本身就有一种双重身份，因为他们经常改名字。
Well, I know that Superman at first, though, is a bit more grounded, I would say. Well, it comes, I mean, in more recent ones, I know it is more rooted. But I think kind of, you know, through the 40s, 50s, 60s, these are, I mean, it's not, it's, well, it's for children. Well, let's start with Superman, because Superman's the first canonical superhero, isn't he, I suppose. He's born in 1938, middle of 1938. And what makes him emblematic of the sort of story generally is like so many of these superheroes, they're created by Jewish writers and illustrators who are themselves kind of dual identity because they've changed their names often.
对，我认为这是另一个不认为这必然是基督教产物的理由，因为人们经常谈论超人，难道不是吗？我的意思是，他来自氪星（Krypton），那个星球毁灭了，然后他死而复生，诸如此类的事情。是的。我的意思是，那是——但有些作家说这是摩西的故事，
Right, which is, I think, another reason for not thinking that this is necessarily Christian, because people so often say about Superman, isn't he? I mean, he comes from Krypton, which dies, and he's reborn and all this kind of stuff. Yeah. I mean, that's... But some writers have said it's the story of Moses
在芦苇丛中或者别的什么。所以我想其中可能包含某些那样的元素。嗯，就像——就像后来对蜘蛛侠的塑造一样，
in the bull rushes or whatever. So I think there are elements perhaps of that. Um, as, as there comes to be with, with, um, with Spider-Man as well,
也许其中回响着某些圣经先知的呼召，去拯救他们的人民。但我认为——我真的、真的认为，这一点不应该被过度解读。我的意思是，这些——这些基本上，在我看来，是关于——这里有一个问题，
that perhaps there are echoes of kind of biblical prophets who were called to, to save their people. But I think that I really, really think it's, this should not be overdone. I mean, these are, these are basically, it seems to me fantasies about, well, so there's a question
来自汤姆·麦泰格（Tom McTague），他是《大西洋月刊》（The Atlantic）一位杰出的政治记者。超级英雄本质上是右翼保守派吗？因为他们是个体英雄主义的浪漫幻想，将荣誉和正义带回一个腐朽的世界？这在我看来，基本上就是他们所关乎的。你觉得那是——但我认为——我不觉得，因为我认为他们是清理小镇的警长。让我们以超人为例，超人在《动作漫画》（Action Comics）第一期中登场，是在——实际上是38年的春天，不是吗？他把一辆车砸向某人。这一期的日期是6月，但他在春天就出现了。他是两个人合作的产物，他们
here from Tom McTague, a very distinguished political journalist for The Atlantic. Are superheroes essentially right-wing conservative as they are romantic fantasies of individual heroism, restoring honour and justice to a decadent world? And that does seem to me, basically, to be what they're about. You think that's what, but I don't see i don't think i think because i think they're sheriffs cleaning up the town let's take superman superman is emerges in action comics number one in uh it's actually the spring of the car isn't he's 38 throwing a car on someone the issue is dated june but he appears in the spring he's the product of two guys they're
非常年轻，分别是杰瑞·西格尔（Jerry Siegel）和乔·舒斯特（Joe Shuster）。他们在高中相遇——犹太背景，实际上拥有许多这种阿什肯纳兹（Ashkenazi）东欧犹太血统。他们改了名字，并且被排挤在纽约出版界之外，不是吗？对，没错。而这几乎是所有这些人的真实写照，他们在某种程度上都经历过挣扎。他们的漫画书被视为下流低俗（de classe），确实如此。但他们之所以去写漫画书，是因为那基本上是他们唯一能够——通过写作获得报酬的方式。完全如此。所以他们创造了超人，而超人诞生于1938年，所以美国其实仍然真正处于大萧条的魔掌之中，比英国持续的时间更长。所以——它的政治氛围非常狂热。超人的角色，他的服装——
very young and they're jerry siegel and joe schuster they have met at high school um jewish background actually sort of so many of these people have got ashkenazi eastern european jewish roots they've changed their names and they're frozen out of kind of new york publishing aren't they right yes and that's actually the case of almost all these people that they have struggled in some way their comic books are seen as de classe they are but they go into writing comic books because that's essentially the only way that they can exactly get paid for writing exactly so they create superman and superman it's 1938 so america is still actually really in the grip of the great depression later than britain is so um it's politically very febrile. The Superman character, the costume,
我直到查阅相关资料才想到这一点——他是以马戏团大力士为原型的。是的，没错。他把内裤穿在外面。内裤和紧身衣，我的意思是，这在今天的我们看来是如此荒谬，但在当时，这被视为巨大力量的象征。男子气概。是的，绝对的。
it hadn't occurred to me until I sort of read up on this, that he's based on circus strongmen. Yes, that's right. He wears his pants outside. The pants and the tights, I mean, which seems so laughable to us today, at the time were seen as emblematic of great strength. Masculinity. Yeah, absolutely.
一点也不荒谬——因为荒谬是个大力士和健身的超级粉丝。我的意思是，这确实有点荒谬。我的意思是，这是一种秀场艺术。我的意思是，是的，我猜马戏团知道你看到的是假的东西，但他们——他们在30年代也是这么看的吗？他们是用同样的眼光看的吗？我不觉得。他们看待它的眼光和我们——也许吧，但在某种程度上，我认为——但一开始，超人具有这种社会活动家的属性，所以他要对付腐败的商人和金融家，那些剥削穷人的人。这其中有一种明确的自由派新政政治色彩。是的——但这也是——为什么你必须依靠一个超人来为你做这件事？为什么你不能依靠警察？为什么你不能依靠强有力的工会？这就是你所说的强有力的工会？
Not at all ridiculous um because ridiculous is a big fan of strong men and fitness i mean it is a bit ridiculous i mean it is a kind of showmanship i mean yes i suppose circus knowing that you're seeing something that's not real but do they see that do they see that in the 30s they see that same eyes i don't they see it quite the same eyes as we well maybe but to a degree i think but at the beginning superman has this sort of social activist side so he's taking on crooked businessmen crooked financiers people who are exploiting the poor there's a definite kind of liberal new deal politics yeah but but it's also i mean why do why do you have to rely on a superman to do that for you why can't you rely on the police why can't you rely on strong trade unions is that what you're strong
完全如此。你必须——你知道的，你必须求助于这个穿着内裤的大个子。但还有另外两个政治要素。一个是——嗯，克拉克·肯特这个角色，也就是那个受压迫、遭轻视、最后咸鱼翻身的书呆子形象——在两次世界大战之间的文化中，这是一个相当常见的主题。英国人称之为“小人物”（the little man），也就是那种被低估、被看不起，但实际上战胜了所有那些——我的意思是，这也是——你知道的，在美国有点像霍雷ショ·阿尔杰（Horatio Alger）式的穷小子发迹的故事。我的意思是，这绝对植根于当时的文化。另一件事是，许多撰写关于漫画书文章的人指出，超人
trade unions exactly you have to you know you have to turn to this kind of big guy with with his pants but there are two other political elements one is that um uh the clark kent character the character of the sort of downtrodden nerdy guy who comes good um that's quite a theme in kind of interwar culture the little man people would call it in brit, the sort of the underrated, underestimated chap who actually triumphs over all those who've... I mean, that's also, you know, slightly Horatio Alger in America, the kind of the poor boy made good kind of thing. I mean, that's absolutely rooted in the culture of the time. The other thing is that a lot of people who've written about comic books point out that Superman
当然是一个移民。是的，他是个新来的人。因为他来自氪星。他总得从某个地方来。但这些故事的创作者通常本身就是第二代移民。所以这是一种局外人融入美国生活方式的过程。
is, of course, an immigrant. Yeah, he's a newcomer. Because he's come from Krypton. He's got to come from somewhere. But these stories are written by people who are often second-generation immigrants themselves. So it's the sort of assimilation into the American way
超人的故事里有这种元素。尽管在某种程度上，超人并没有真正融入，不是吗？我的意思是，那是——超人故事中的核心所在。尽管——但在某种程度上，超人并没有真正融入，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是重点。我的意思是，所有这些超级英雄从长远来看都没有融入，这成了一个主题。是的，一直延续到今天。你知道的，因为X战警是变种人，蝙蝠侠基本上是个精神病患者。我的意思是，所有这些人，以及对这些故事更精妙的重新加工，都在利用这样一个事实：
of outsiders. And that's there in the Superman story. Although in a way Superman isn't assimilated, is he? I mean, that's the in the superman story although uh in a way superman isn't assimilated is he i mean that's the point i mean all these superheroes are not in the long run assimilated and that becomes a theme yeah the way up to the present day you know because x-men are mutants um batman's basically a kind of psychopath i mean all these people and the more kind of sophisticated reworkings of these stories make play with the fact
实际上，这些穿着斗篷披风、到处揍人的家伙身上，存在着某种棘手的东西。嗯，我认为——所以克拉克·肯特和超人大概是移民精神分裂特质的一种体现。是的，既有归属感又不属于这里，我猜是这样的。移民的精神分裂特质。是的。
that actually there's something slightly difficult about these people in capes and cloaks kind of beating people up. Well, I think... So Clark Kent and Superman is presumably a kind of embodiment of the schizophrenic quality of an immigrant. Yeah, both belonging and not belonging, I suppose so. Of an immigrant. Yeah.
既有归属感又不属于这里，我猜是这样的。这也是真的。我的意思是，这几乎是精神分裂式的。我的意思是，蝙蝠侠。所以蝙蝠侠是什么时候被创造出来的？一年后？鲍勃·凯恩（Bob Kane），实际上是罗伯特·卡恩（Robert Kahn），另一个阿什肯纳兹犹太作家。鲍勃·凯恩和比尔·芬格（Bill Finger）。所以那是1939年3月的《侦探漫画》（Detective Comics）。现在，蝙蝠侠
Both belonging and not belonging, I suppose. And that's also true. I mean, it's almost schizophrenic. I mean, Batman. So Batman is created, what, a year later? Bob Kane, who's actually Robert Kahn, another Ashkenazi Jewish writer. Bob Kane and Bill Finger. So that's Detective Comics in March 1939. Now, Batman
有点不同，因为他——他没有超能力，对吧？没有。所以他真的是哥谭市的红花侠。他是一个富有的、不负责任的贵族，或者是一个看起来像是那种人的人，就像布鲁斯·韦恩。甚至克里斯托弗·诺兰（Christopher Nolan）的电影也有这个元素。
is slightly different because he's... He doesn't have a superpower, does he? No. So he really is the Scarlet Pimpernel in Gotham City. He is a rich, feckless aristocrat or somebody who appears to be that, like Bruce Wayne. And even the Christopher Nolan films have that element to them.
他的父母被抢劫犯杀害了。对。然后成了一个治安维持者。所以显然，你可以把这看作是对犯罪等一系列问题的焦虑的反映。这是一个巨大的问题。是的。他为什么打扮成一只蝙蝠？
His parents have been killed by muggers. Right. And becomes a vigilante. So obviously that's kind of, you can see that as reflecting anxieties about crime and all that sort of stuff. And a huge question. Yeah. Why does he dress up as a bat?
嗯，人们一直在讨论——关于这个有很多争论，因为所有这些角色有趣的地方在于，作家和插画家之间总是会随后爆发争端，争论谁才是真正的发明者。有一种说法是，他们蝙蝠翅膀的灵感来自于列奥纳多·达·芬奇（Leonardo da Vinci），是的，这个扑翼机（ornithopter）——是的，飞行器。但是，你知道他为什么叫布鲁斯·韦恩吗？不，所以他的名字——据编剧比尔·芬格说，布鲁斯·韦恩的名字来自罗伯特·布鲁斯（Robert the Bruce）。
Well, there's people have sort of talked, there's been lots of arguments about this because what's interesting with all these characters is there's always subsequent rows between the writer and the illustrator about who the real inventor is there's a claim isn't there that they got the inspiration for the bat wings from leonardo da vinci yes this ornithocta yes flying machine um but you know why he's called bruce wayne uh no so his his name says bill finger the writer bruce Bruce Wayne's first name came from Robert the Bruce.
哦，他是苏格兰人。然后他想找一个能让美国人联想到殖民主义的名字。他尝试过亚当斯（Adams）、汉考克（Hancock），类似于国父、美国独立战争时期的历史人物。然后我想到了“疯子”安东尼·韦恩（Mad Anthony Wayne），显然我以前从没听说过他。他是美国独立战争时期的将军。他给了他们这个名字。所以因此就有了布鲁斯·韦恩。伟大的播客主持人之一是——蝙蝠侠是——好吧，我们都在学习。
Oh, he's Scottish. And he then thought he wanted a name that reminded Americans of colonialism. He tried Adams, Hancock, sort of founding fathers, U.S. War of Independence figures. And then I thought of Mad Anthony Wayne, who apparently I'd never heard of him, actually. He's a general in the American-US War of Independence. And he gives them that name. So hence, Bruce Wayne. One of the great podcasters is. Batman is, well, we're both learning.
我们一直在学习，汤姆。嗯，我所学到的——我确实觉得这太神奇了。这带来了一个小问题，因为这是一个播客。但小丑（The Joker）。是的。蝙蝠侠的长期死敌——他的外貌显然取材于1928年的那部无声电影《笑面人》（The Man Who Laughs），主演是一个叫康拉德·韦特（Conrad Veidt）的人。你以前看过那个吗？
We're learning all the time, Tom. Well, I did what I learned. I did think this was amazing. And it's a slight problem because this is a podcast. But the Joker. Yeah. Batman's long-running adversary um the look of him apparently came from this 1928 silent film the man who laughs yeah featuring a guy conrad fight had you seen that
所以我查了一下，我的意思是，我不知道他们怎么能逃过侵权。这简直一模一样。它就是一模一样的。但这就是现在所有这些漫画书的运作方式。我的意思是，它们被视为非常低俗的儿童娱乐。所以显然他们在大肆抄袭、左抄右抄。当然他们能蒙混过关，因为当时没有人认为他们正在创造能延续到21世纪的系列作品。他们只是认为这是一次性的、会被瞬间遗忘的通俗小说。所以你有所有这些——
before so i looked it up and it's i mean i don't know how they got away with it it's exactly the same it is exactly but that's how all these comic books work nowadays. I mean, they're seen as very kind of lowbrow kids' entertainment. So obviously they're ripping off things left, right and centre. And of course they get away with it because no one thinks at the time they're creating franchises that will last the 21st century. They just think this is disposable pulp fiction that will be almost instantly forgotten. So you have all these.
我相信你有一个——你难道没有一份有趣的、你不知道的角色名单吗？我有。我有。因为，当然，超人和蝙蝠侠非常成功，并且大概在战争期间得到了极大推动，对吧？是的，我想是的。所以他们在与希特勒战斗。
I believe you have a... Do you not have some sort of list of amusing characters you didn't? I do. I do. Because, of course, Superman and Batman, very successful, and presumably turbocharged by the war, right? Yeah, I think so. So they're fighting Hitler.
美国队长（Captain America）。美国队长，当然。与希特勒战斗等等。所以在整个战争期间，你看到了超级英雄的大爆发。所以有一些没能成功。这就是超级英雄为了生存而进行的达尔文式斗争。所以有法蒂玛夫人（Madame Fatal）。这是一个好名字。
Captain America. Captain America, of course. Fighting Hitler and everything. And so through the war, the war years, you have this vast explosion of superheroes. And so there were some that didn't make it. So this kind of Darwinian struggle for superheroes to make it through. So there was Madame Fatal. That's a good name.
她实际上是理查德·斯坦顿（Richard Stanton），这很好——她实际上是理查德·斯坦顿，一个退休的演员，伪装成老太太去打击犯罪。好吧，那不是——我能理解为什么那个行不通——这个是——卡佩尔·洛夫特（Capel Loft）提到的一个——他显然在试图拍我们的马屁，此前曾是节目的朋友，然后变成了一个——嗯，他建立了一个竞争性的国王与王后世界杯，但现在他真的——他改过自新了。他确实洗心革面了，他提名了“迪肯”（The Deacon），这是一个改过自新的江洋大盗，伪装成英国国教会牧师去打击犯罪。我——我无法理解为什么那个没有流行起来。为什么他们不拿他开玩笑？
Who was actually Richard Stanton, that's good who was who was actually richard stanton a retired actor who fought crime disguised as an old lady okay that wasn't i can see why that didn't work out um this this is one uh mentioned by capel loft who is obviously trying to suck up to us after formerly a friend of the show then kind of a well he set up a rival world cup of kings and queens but now he's really he's changed his ways he has he's reformed um and he he nominated the deacon who is a reformed burglar who who fights crime disguised as a church of england clergyman i can't i can't understand why that hasn't caught on why don't they make fun of him
为什么汤姆·霍兰德不演迪肯？这就是我的问题。还有同性恋幽灵（The Gay Ghost）。同性恋幽灵是什么？同性恋幽灵是——一个18世纪的爱尔兰贵族，他是个幽灵。对，好吧——那是超能力吗？他是一个——他是一个——好吧，我也可以，是的。超级——有一个超级反派叫体育健将（Sportsmaster），他的恶行包括向人们扔运动器材。嗯，就像一种板球护具或者一些路标锥。嗯，我当时有点在想，你知道的，50年代体育课上你跳过的那种东西。类似于跨栏。
why isn't tom holland playing the deacon that's my question there's the gay ghost the gay what's the gay ghost the gay ghost is uh an 18th century nobleman in ireland who's a ghost right okay um that's a superpower he's a he's a he's okay i can also yeah uh super there's a superillain called the Sportsmaster whose villainy consists of throwing sports kit at people. Well, like kind of a cricket box or like some cones. Well, I was kind of thinking, you know, those things that you jump over in 1950s gyms. Sort of hurdles.
是的，还有实心球之类。但我的意思是，非常——其实我会觉得那挺吓人的。是的，我懂。但我的意思是，你怎么能一边去银行抢劫或干别的，一边扛着一大袋满满的运动器材，以防你遭到攻击呢？
Yeah, and medicine balls and things like that. But I mean, quite... I would find that terrifying, actually. Yeah, I know. But I mean, how do you go around being, you know, robbing banks or whatever, lugging a great bag full of sports kit just in case you're attacked?
所以你能理解为什么那个没有成功。太糟糕了。还有一个家伙有很多蜜蜂。不，没有——一个有很多蜜蜂的家伙。一个在皮带里藏了很多蜜蜂、并把它们放出来的人。我不记得他叫什么了，
So you can kind of see why that one didn't work out. Yeah. That's terrible. There's a fellow who's got a lot of bees. No, there's no... A man who's got a lot of bees. A man who's got lots of bees hidden in his belt, and he releases them. I can't remember what he's called,
红蜂（The Red Bee）还是什么的。是的。不管怎样，这一切都非常——但是某个人——这和古代先驱毫无关系。嗯，没有，但这确实是历史，不是吗？因为，我的意思是，这是20世纪30年代和40年代的文化。确实是。但我想说的是，这并非汲取根深蒂固的文化记忆。好吧，给你介绍一个角色，汤姆，他确实汲取了根深蒂固的记忆，
the red bee or something like that. Yeah. Anyway, it's all very... But somebody who's... It has nothing to do with the ancient antecedents. Well, no, but it's history, isn't it? Because, I mean, it's the culture of the 1930s and 40s. It is. But what I'm saying is that this is not drawing on deep-rooted cultural memories. Okay, here's a character for you, Tom, that does draw on deep-rooted memories,
也就是亚马逊人的神话。所以我们谈论的所有角色都已经存在了。神奇女侠（Wonder Woman）。神奇女侠。所以神奇女侠登场了。我们有了超人（38年）、蝙蝠侠（39年）。神奇女侠在1941年登场。她是戴安娜公主。
i.e. the myth of the Amazons. So all the characters we talked about have been there. Wonder Woman. Wonder Woman. So Wonder Woman, she arrives. So we've had Superman, 38, Batman, 39. Wonder Woman comes along in 1941. And she is Princess Diana.
亚马逊人。来自Themyscira（天堂岛），一个住满了亚马逊人的岛屿。她是希波吕忒女王（Queen Hippolyta）的女儿。是的。所以她有着非常了不起的古代世界血统，对吧？确实如此。
Of the Amazons. Of Themyscira, which is an island inhabited by Amazons. She's the daughter of Queen Hippolyta. Yeah. Yes. So she has a very impressive kind of ancient world pedigree, doesn't she? She does.
但她——你知道的，这依然是《本先生》。因为实际上神奇女侠所取材的，并不是对古希腊的深刻记忆，而是一个叫威廉·莫尔顿·马斯顿（William Moulton Marston）的家伙的幻想，他是一位心理学教授。据说他是测谎仪的发明者，不是吗？但显然他是从他妻子那里抄来的。
But she is, you know, this is still Mr. Ben. Right. Because actually what Wonder Woman is drawing on is not deep memories of ancient Greece, but the fantasies of a guy called William Moulton Marston, who was a professor of psychology. He's said to be the inventor of the lie detector, isn't he? But apparently he ripped it off from his wife.
他妻子发明的。然后他把功劳揽到了自己身上。嗯，这是一个非凡的故事。所以他就像是一个受过哈佛教育的心理学家，他（不仅由他自己）被归功于发明了多谱描记器（测谎仪）并做了所有这些事情。但他撒谎了。他的性格实际上——是的，具有讽刺意味的是，所有这些性格——所以他跟另一个叫伊丽莎白的心理学家结婚了，但他们住在一起——他们有一种——甚至不是——他们三个人一起生活在婚姻中，真的有三个人在这段婚姻里。还有奥利弗·伯恩（Olive Byrne）。
His wife invented it. And he then kind of passed it off. Well, this is an extraordinary story. So he's like a Harvard-educated psychologist who's credited, not least by himself, with having invented the polygraph and doing all this. But he lied. His personality is actually well ironically um all these personalities yes so he is married to another psychologist called elizabeth but they live with they have a kind of they have it's not
他们总是互相捆绑。所以神奇女侠当然有她的真言套索。是的。她总是把人绑起来。但更贴切的是，神奇女侠本人总是被铁链捆绑、束缚、堵住嘴。而且他对此完全毫不掩饰，不是吗？嗯，不，他写得越多，
even it's not yeah they have the three of them in it they really are three of them in this marriage yeah and they're always tying each other up olive Olive Byrne. And they're always doing bondage with each other and stuff. And so Wonder Woman, of course, has her magic lasso. Yeah. She's always tying people up. But more germainly, Wonder Woman herself is always being chained, bound, gagged. And he's completely upfront about this, isn't he? Well, no, but the more he writes them
捆绑的元素就越多。所以其中有一个很棒的台词，有一次神奇女侠甚至大喊：“阿芙洛狄忒的伟大腰带啊！我厌倦了被捆绑。”但你知道的，她其实并没有——你知道的，她很喜欢。他对此完全毫不掩饰。所以他迷恋漫画书，他认为这是通往——他们非常——关于这个他非常理想主义、非常高雅，马斯顿和伯恩——或者他们叫什么名字——他自己说：“神奇女侠是对新型女性的心理宣传，我认为这种女性应该统治世界。”他说：“许多女孩缺乏力量、强壮和威力。”
the more the more the bondage comes in exactly so there's this great line at one point wonder woman actually cries out great girdle of aphrodite i'm so tired of being tied up but you know she isn't really you know she loves it he he's utterly upfront about it so he's fascinated by comic books he thinks they're the way to he's they're very about it so he's fascinated by comic books he thinks they're the way to he's they're very kind of idealistic kind of highbrow people marston and and marston and burn or whatever they're called and he says he says himself wonder woman is psychological propaganda for the new type of woman who i believe should rule the world he says too many girls lack force strength and power
越是这样，束缚就越深。确实如此，其中有一句很棒的台词：神奇女侠甚至大喊‘阿芙洛狄忒伟大的束腰啊，我厌倦了被捆绑’，但你知道她并非真的厌倦，你知道她其实很喜欢。他对这一点毫不掩饰，他迷恋漫画书，认为这是通往……他们非常理想主义，有点阳春白雪的感觉，马斯顿和伯恩，不管他们叫什么。他自己也说过：‘神奇女侠是为新型女性准备的心理宣传，我认为这种女性应该统治世界。’他说，许多女孩缺乏魄力、力量和权势。
he wants to the obvious remedy is to create a feminine character with all the strength of superman plus all the allure of a good and beautiful woman well he he but he thinks that there is strength in submission so there's an amazing plot where wonder woman rescues um a group of women who've been enslaved by an evil Nazi and the Nazi gets defeated. But the twist is that the girls who've been rescued then miss being slaves. So Wonder Woman sends them off to the Amazons
显然，显而易见的解决办法是创造一个兼具超人的全部力量以及善良美丽女子的全部魅力的女性角色。好吧，但他认为顺从之中蕴含着力量，因此有一个非常精彩的情节：神奇女侠拯救了一群被一个邪恶纳粹奴役的妇女，然后纳粹被打败了。但转折是，那些被解救的女孩竟然怀念起当奴隶的日子。于是神奇女侠把她们送到了亚马逊人那里，
where they can all live happily as slaves. It's very strange. There's another quote from him here. The only hope for peace is to teach people who are full of pep and unbound force to enjoy being bound only when the control of self by others is more pleasant than the unbound assertion of self can we hope for a stable peaceful human society and the risks the risk the risk of of women not being allowed to express this um is conveyed through the character of Dr. Poison.
她们可以在那里作为奴隶幸福地生活。这非常奇怪。这里还有他的另一句话：“和平的唯一希望，是教导那些充满活力和不受约束的力量的人，去享受受到约束的乐趣。只有当他人对自我的控制比不受约束的自我张扬更令人愉快时，我们才能期盼一个稳定、和平的人类社会。”而妇女不被允许表达这种情感的风险，则是通过毒药博士这个角色传达出来的。
Tell me about Dr. Poison. So Dr. Poison is an evil supervillain who loves humiliating women, confronts Wonder Woman, and amazingly is revealed to be a woman whose love of submission has been frustrated and therefore has corrupted her into becoming this evil figure. Yeah. So you can see why there aren't deep waters. And obviously in the 1950s, there was this tremendous backlash, wasn't there? Yes.
跟我讲讲毒药博士。毒药博士是一个喜欢羞辱女性的邪恶超级反派，她与神奇女侠对抗，令人惊奇的是，她被揭示其实也是一个女性，而她对顺从的热爱受到了压抑，因此导致她堕落成了这样一个邪恶的人物。是的。所以你能看出为什么这些作品并没有什么深意。显然，在20世纪50年代，出现了一次巨大的强烈反弹，对吧？是的。
And there's this guy who's himself a kind of a psychiatrist, I think, called Frederick Wertham, who writes a book called The Seduction of the Innocent, published in 1954, which causes this tremendous stir. It's taken up by congressional hearings and stuff, where he basically says comic books and superhero stories are corrupting youth. He says at one point, kids who read Superman won't listen to their parents or teachers because their parents and teachers will seem so weak and bland by comparison. Ergo, we should stamp out Superman. But I mean, that's that's the kind of equivalent of saying that we can't allow vigilantes and sheriffs to kind of shoot people in the Wild West.
有这么一个人，他自己本身某种程度上也是个精神病医生，我想，他叫弗雷德里克·韦瑟姆，他写了一本名为《诱惑无辜》的书，于1954年出版，引起了极大的轰动。这本书被国会听证会等机构所采纳，他在书中基本上声称漫画书和超级英雄故事正在腐蚀年轻人。他有一次说，读超人的孩子不会听父母或老师的话，因为相比之下，他们的父母和老师会显得那么软弱和乏味。因此，我们应该消灭超人。但我的意思是，这就好比说我们不能允许义务警员和治安官在狂野西部枪杀别人一样。
That exactly proves my point. Well, I mean, the interesting thing is he's loathed and hated by comic book enthusiasts because they see him as having... But obviously, some of the things that he identifies, so he identifies the bondage. And he does identify what some people might see as a slightly fascistic, or you clearly see as a slightly fascistic element to superhero stories. So the idea of a Superman, somebody with powers who takes the law into their own hands. Wortham says in 1954, all this stuff is terrible. And I guess some people today will probably agree with him. them well i mean i think that that's what's interesting about the the turn that public morality has taken which is that actually it's a reprise of quite a lot of perspectives in the 50s so now you know in the 60s and 70s and 80s you know brilliant bondage woohoo now it's it's seen as more problematic again or is it uh you know these these are and i guess that that's why superheroes are interesting is that they do hold a mirror up to, because they're an incredibly democratic, incredibly popular form.
这正好证明了我的观点。好吧，我的意思是，有趣的是，他被漫画爱好者深恶痛绝，因为他们认为他……但显然，他所指出的一些东西，比如他指出了受虐邦德情节。他确实指出了某些人可能会认为是略带法西斯主义，或者你显然认为是略带法西斯主义的超级英雄故事元素。也就是超人的概念，一个拥有超能力并私自执法的人。韦瑟姆在1954年说，所有这些东西都太可怕了。我想现在有些人可能还会同意他的观点。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这就是公共道德发生转变的有趣之处，实际上，这可以说是对50年代许多观点的重演——所以在60年代、70年代和80年代，“太棒了，受虐癖，呜呼”；现在，它再次被视为更具问题性的事物，或者说……这些就是……我想这就是超级英雄之所以有趣的原因，因为它们确实为我们提供了一面镜子，因为它们是一种极其民主、极其大众化的形式。
They do hold up a really, really fascinating mirror to the way that neuroses and cultural anxieties and morality panics and virtue spirals operate in the United States over the past century. And you say the United States because they are, it's interesting, they have, of course, been attempts to have, there was Captain Britain and so on, but they are really specifically American, aren't they? And I think that's why I was never interested in them, particularly. Because you're Americanophobic. No, it's just, they just seem very, very foreign to me.
它们为过去一个世纪美国神经症、文化焦虑、道德恐慌和美德漩涡的运作方式，提供了一面非常非常迷人的镜子。你之所以说美国，是因为有趣的是，当然也有过尝试出现英国队长等等，但它们确实具有极具针对性的美国特色，对吧？我想这也是为什么我对它们从来不怎么感兴趣的原因。因为你患有“反美恐惧症”。不，只是它们对我来说显得非常非常陌生。
So I guess, I mean, I had no problem reading Asterix. I loved Asterix and Tintin. They seem kind of part of the world that I inhabited. But these, you know, square-jawed men with trilbies in mean streets. I mean, it was a long way from Wiltshire. Well, this is your Ted Heath-ism, isn't it? Ted Heath would agree with you. He would see you as a great, you know, when he was taking Britain into Europe,
所以我想，也就是说，我读《阿历克斯历险记》完全没有问题。我喜欢《阿历克斯历险记》和《丁丁历险记》。它们似乎是我所处世界的一部分。但这些……你知道的，在残酷街道上戴着呢帽的方下巴男人。我的意思是，这离威尔特郡可太远了。好吧，这就是你的“爱德华·希思主义”，对吧？爱德华·希思会同意你的看法。他会把你视作一个伟大的……你知道的，当他带领英国加入欧洲时，
you as a fellow Wiltshire enthusiast. But think the other reason why the other and this kind of opens up that maybe the next stage I'll just say this before we go to the break is that um rather like I never took James Bond seriously because I grew up with um Roger Moore as James Bond so also basically my introduction to superheroes was um Adam West and Burt Ward as Batman and Robin, which was played almost entirely for laughs. Completely for laughs. So, you know, the bat shark repellent gas. The pow-wam kind of stuff that appears on screen. Yes, exactly.
你作为一个同道中人的威尔特郡爱好者。但我觉得另一个原因——这也引出了接下来的阶段，我在我们休息前先说这个——那就是……就像我从来不把詹姆斯·邦德当回事一样，因为我是看着罗杰·摩尔演的詹姆斯·邦德长大的；同样，我接触超级英雄基本上也是通过亚当·韦斯特和伯特·沃德饰演的蝙蝠侠和罗宾，这部剧几乎完全是当成喜剧来演的。完全是为了搞笑。所以，你知道的，蝙蝠鲨鱼驱虫剂毒气。屏幕上出现的那些“砰”、“啪”之类的字眼。是的，完全如此。
And the villains. So Vincent Price's egghead. There was the professor who kept turning into Tutankhamen. I love that. There was Cesar Romero as the Joker who refused to shave his moustache. So they've painted over it, haven't they? They've just painted over it. And I was watching some of the footage.
还有反派们。文森特·普莱斯饰演的蛋头。还有那个不断变成图坦卡蒙的教授。我太喜欢那个了。还有塞萨尔·罗梅罗饰演的小偷拒绝刮掉他的小胡子。所以他们直接把胡子给涂盖住了，对吧？他们就直接在上面涂了一层颜料。我当时在看一些当年的影像资料。
I hadn't thought about it for years and years, but it was still held up. A routine question. Have you recently sold any war surplus submarines? And if so, to whom? And it's actually, it's Leslie Nielsen. It's the naked gun. Yeah, I can see that.
我已经很多很多年没想过它了，但它依然经得起审视。一个常规问题。你最近卖过任何海军的剩余潜艇吗？如果有，卖给了谁？实际上，那是莱斯利·尼尔森。那是《白头神探》。是的，我能看出来。
And I think, you know, it's, that's basically why I've never been able to take it seriously. Well, let's hope you take it serious in the second half because we will, of course, be coming to your own favourite super hero. Ah, yes, Spider-Man. Spideidey we'll see you after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我想，你知道的，基本上这就是为什么我从来没能认真对待它的原因。好吧，让我们希望你在下半场能认真对待它，因为我们当然会讲到你自己的最爱——超级英雄。啊，是的，蜘蛛侠。小蜘蛛！我们休息一会儿再见，我是玛丽亚·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐其余》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八盒八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. So Dominic, before we get back to superheroes, it is time to talk about UnHerd, our favourite online magazine. Yes. And regular listeners will remember that a couple of weeks ago you were talking about an article that you had in the works and I asked you to say what it was and you were being very coy about it.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。那么，多米尼克，在我们回到超级英雄之前，是时候聊聊 UnHerd 了，这是我们最喜欢的在线杂志。是的。经常收听的听众会记得，几周前你提到过你有一篇文章正在筹备中，我问你写的是什么，而你当时对此支支吾吾。
I didn't want to tell you. Well, it's now come out, hasn't it? And what was it about? It was all about, so it's the 20th anniversary of the release of The Fellowship of the Ring the first Gerard Tolkien Peter Jackson Lord of the Rings
我不想告诉你。好吧，它现在已经发表了，对吧？讲的是什么内容？它完全是关于……所以今年是《魔戒》第一部——杰拉尔·托尔金、彼得·杰克逊的《魔戒》——上映20周年。
Peter Jackson film and who then went on to do better things Peter Jackson get back it's not better than the Lord of the Rings
彼得·杰克逊的电影，他后来去做了更好的事情，彼得·杰克逊的《指环王：回归》——这可不比《魔戒》好。
it's very similar are you mad are you mad group of friends overcoming terrible odds tribulation to achieve great things
它们非常相似。你疯了吗？你疯了吗？一群朋友克服可怕的逆境和苦难来取得伟大的成就。
yeah so it's 20th anniversary of the Lord of the Rings and they said do you have anything to say about the Lord of the Rings films danger and tribulation to achieve great things. Yeah, so it's the 20th anniversary of The Lord of the Rings and they said, do you have anything to say about The Lord of the Rings films or the Lord, well really the Tolkien phenomenon. And I always have things to say about Tolkien, as you know. And the people at UnHerd were very kind enough to indulge me. But you're
是的，所以这是《魔戒》上映20周年，他们问你对《魔戒》电影有没有什么要说的，关于危险和苦难以及取得伟大的成就。是的，所以这是《魔戒》上映20周年，他们问，你对《魔戒》电影或者说魔戒——其实也就是托尔金现象——有什么想说的吗？正如你所知，我对托尔金总是有话说。UnHerd 的朋友们也非常包容我。但你
cross because you think I didn't mention I didn't want to come onto your turf. I didn't mention Christianity. I wasn't cross. I thought it was a wonderful essay, as I'd expect, because you're always wonderful on Tolkien. I just felt that if you're talking about Tolkien's inspirations, you might have mentioned Christianity. But that's something for maybe a future episode for us, A future article for you. Yeah. Anyway, on the topic of Christianity, UnHerd are launching a Christmas special offer to celebrate.
很不高兴，因为你觉得我没有提……我不想涉足你的领地。我没有提到基督教。我没有不高兴。我觉得这是一篇精彩的文章，正如我所预料的那样，因为你对托尔金的见解总是无懈可击。我只是觉得，如果你要谈论托尔金的灵感来源，你本可以提到基督教。但这或许是我们未来某一期节目的话题，也是你未来的一篇文章。是的。无论如何，说到基督教，UnHerd 为了庆祝正在推出圣诞特惠活动。
Oh, that's nice. The birth of the baby Jesus. So that's great. So it could be a present for somebody. So you can gift UnHerd membership to a friend or family member for Christmas. I can't believe you used the word gift as a verb. I just did, didn't I? Yeah.
哦，那太好了。为了庆祝耶稣宝宝的诞生。所以这很棒。因此它可以作为送给某人的礼物。所以你可以在圣诞节为朋友或家人购买 UnHerd 会员资格作为礼物。我简直不敢相信你把“礼物”（gift）这个词当作动词用了。我刚才确实用了，不是吗？是的。
Do you do that normally? I started doing it in the London Olympics, where people podiumed and meddled. Oh, meddling. You're very into verbing. Yeah, verbing. Anyway, you're distracting me from what I meant to be reading, which is, if you know someone who could do with confronting some different perspectives, do you, Dominic?
你平时也这样吗？我从伦敦奥运会开始这样用的，当时人们说“登上领奖台”（podiumed）和“获得奖牌”（medalled）。哦，“获得奖牌”。你非常喜欢把名词当作动词用。对，名词动词化。不管怎样，你打断了我要读的内容，那就是：如果你认识某个需要面对不同观点的人，多米尼克，你认识这样的人吗？
Do you know someone who could do with confronting some different perspectives? Yeah, I do. Actually, I know loads of people. Well, in that case, unheard membership could be for them. It says they could benefit from questioning some of their certainties. Yes. Yeah, I do. I know a lot of people like that. All academics. That's your Christmas gift with with sorted then yeah and there's a special offer which brings an annual subscription down 10 pounds to only 39 pounds and there's an unheard bag with this fabulous label on it immune to herd
你认识某个需要面对不同观点的人吗？是的，我认识。实际上，我认识好多这样的人。好吧，如果是这样的话，UnHerd 会员资格就非常适合他们。上面说他们可以从质疑自己的一些笃信中受益。是的。是的，我认识。我认识很多这样的人。全都是学者。那你给他们的圣诞礼物就有着落了。是的，而且有一个特惠活动，年订阅费减少10英镑，仅需39英镑，并且还会赠送一个印有绝妙标语的 UnHerd 布袋：“免疫于乌合之众心态”。
mentality yeah it's again it's again it's that double-edged thing though isn't it because if too many people carry that bag i know imagine they might look like it imagine like a herd that's what worries me i'm always worried with unheard whether somebody will set up a rival website called herd if unheard becomes become too successful but clearly we're not at that stage yet i mean people should definitely visit unheard.com to find out more but do so quickly before the herd arrive. Yeah. Okay. And now back to superheroes. The most popular Marvel hero is much lower on the social scale. He is the maladjusted adolescent Spider-Man, the only overtly neurotic superhero I've ever come across. Spider-Man has a terrible
是的，这又是一个……这又是一个双刃剑的问题，对吧？因为如果太多人背着那个袋子……我懂，想象一下，他们看起来可能会像……想象一下，就像一群牛羊，这就是我所担心的。我一直担心 UnHerd 会不会有人创建一个名为“Herd（牛群）”的竞争网站，如果 UnHerd 变得太成功的话。但显然我们还没到那个阶段。我的意思是，人们绝对应该访问 UnHerd.com 了解更多信息，但要在羊群到来之前抓紧时间。好的。现在回到超级英雄。最受欢迎的漫威英雄在社会阶层上要低得多。他是适应不良的青少年蜘蛛侠，这是我见过唯一的、公开表现出神经质的超级英雄。蜘蛛侠有着可怕的
identity problem, a marked inferiority complex and a fear of women. He's antisocial, castration ridden, wracked with Oedipal guilt and accident prone. How can a character as healthy as Superman compete with this living symbol of the modern dilemma, this neurotics neurotic spider-man the super anti-hero of our time now tom that was the village voice in 1965 do you want to stand up for your alter ego i i i hadn't realized it i i hadn't realized that that's who i was it's just uncanny it's eerie the stuff about castration, for example. I mean, the number of times you brought that up on the podcast and the Village Voice were on your case.
身份认同问题、明显的自卑情结以及对女性的恐慌。他反社会、有阉割焦虑、饱受俄狄浦斯情结的内疚之苦，并且容易发生意外。像超人这样健康的额角色，怎么能与这个现代困境的活生生象征、这个神经质中的神经质——我们这个时代的超级反派蜘蛛侠相提并论呢？好了，汤姆，那是1965年的《乡村之声》报。你想为你的另一个自我辩护吗？我……我之前没意识到……我之前没意识到原来我就是这样的人。这简直太不可思议了，太诡异了，比如关于阉割的那部分。我的意思是，你在播客里提起这个的次数之多，《乡村之声》可是一直在关注你呢。
Yeah, that's amazing. Although, as someone said, I mean, Peter Parker was also, he was chairman of British Rail, wasn't he, in the 70s? He was. Went out with Shirley Williams. Shirley Williams had a crush on Peter Parker when they were at Oxford. So, yes. So we're now coming.
是的，这太神奇了。尽管正如某人所说，彼得·帕克在70年代也曾担任过英国铁路公司的董事长，不是吗？是的。和雪莉·威廉姆斯约会过。雪莉·威廉姆斯在牛津上学时曾对彼得·帕克产生过迷恋。所以，是的。所以我们现在要讲的是——
So the stuff that we're talking about in the first half is known by comic book enthusiasts as the golden age of comics. I thought it was also the silver age. No. No, I think this is the. According to Grant Morrison, the golden age is the Second World War. Yeah. We're about to talk about the Silver Age. And then the Silver Age is the 1950s.
我们在前半部分讨论的内容，被漫画爱好者称为漫画的黄金时代。我还以为那也是白银时代呢。不。不，我认为这是……根据格兰特·莫里森的说法，黄金时代是第二次世界大战时期。是的。我们接下来要谈论的是白银时代。白银时代则是20世纪50年代。
So what's Spider-Man? When Superman was drawn by an artist called Wayne Boring. I knew you wanted to mention Wayne Boring. Yeah, I did. I think the Silver Age goes into the 60s. So that's where you get the second... It's like debates over the Renaissance, isn't it?
那么蜘蛛侠算什么？当超人是由一个叫韦恩·博林（Wayne Boring）的艺术家绘制的时候。我就知道你想提韦恩·博林。是的，我确实想提。我认为白银时代一直延续到了60年代。所以这就是你获得第二部……这就像关于文艺复兴的争论，对吧？
When does it begin? When does it end? The crazy rabbit holes. The long 19th century. I've spent hours on the internet just getting deeper and deeper. It totally has my depth on the difference. So there's two different Captain Marvels, one belonging to DC and one to Marvel, very confusingly. So tell me about DC and Marvel.
它何时开始？何时结束？陷入疯狂的兔子洞。漫长的19世纪。我曾在互联网上花了好几个小时，越陷越深。它完全触及了我对差异的认知。所以有两个不同的惊奇队长（Captain Marvel），一个属于DC，一个属于漫威，这非常令人困惑。所以跟我讲讲DC和漫威吧。
I don't understand this. So they're just rival companies. It's very simple. And they're rival companies, So they're just rival companies. It's very simple. And they're rival companies, and they're both associated with slightly different eras. So they've always had different names. So DC is the classic ones. So DC is Batman, Superman, and so on. Marvel's heyday comes in the so-called Silver Age.
我不明白这一点。所以它们只是竞争对手公司？很简单。它们是竞争对手公司，所以它们只是竞争对手公司。很简单。它们是竞争对手公司，并且都与略有不同的时代相关联。所以它们一直有着不同的名字。DC是经典的那种。所以DC是蝙蝠侠、超人等等。漫威的全盛期出现在所谓的白银时代。
And they have Stan Lee, and a guy called called Jack Kirby and a guy called Steve Ditko. Again, all of them, you know, we've got Jewish backgrounds, dual identities, New York, based in New York. And this is the one that's a coherent world. Yes. And what they do, which is brilliant, is that they, unlike DC,
他们有斯坦·李、一个叫杰克·科比的人和一个叫史蒂夫·迪特科的人。同样，他们所有人，你知道的，我们都有犹太血统，双重身份，来自纽约，总部设在纽约。而这是一个连贯的世界。是的。他们所做的一件极其出色事情是，与DC不同，
realise that they have to adjust to a new, a completely new kind of generational tone in the early 1960s. They do it first with a team called the Fantastic Four. My son absolutely adores the Fantastic Four. The Fantastic Four starts in 1961. Mr Fantastic, the Invisible Woman, the Human Torch and the Thing. And they're a kind of family group. It's very space age, unlike...
他们意识到自己必须在20世纪60年代初适应一种全新的、完全不同的一代人的基调。他们首先通过一个名为“神奇四侠”的团队做到了这一点。我儿子非常喜欢《神奇四侠》。《神奇四侠》始于1961年。神奇先生、隐形女侠、霹雳火和石头人。他们是一个类似家庭的团体。这非常具有太空时代感，不像……
So the earlier ones, Batman and so on, feel very 1930s. These guys are astronauts. They are fighting the communists. They want to get into space. And this is against the backdrop of Kennedy, space race. Exactly. Because in the early ones, scientists are kind of villains. Yeah.
所以早期的作品，比如蝙蝠侠等等，感觉非常具有20世纪30年代的风格。而这些家伙是宇航员。他们在与共产主义者战斗。他们想要进入太空。这是在肯尼迪时代、太空竞赛的背景下诞生的。完全正确。因为在早期的作品中，科学家基本上都是反派。是的。
And they're always... Whereas now, almost all the Marvel heroes of the 60s, science has gone wrong in some way, but science is also their friend and their weapon. And actually, the US State Department supposedly had said to publishers, we want you to push science, we want you to embrace science, because they obviously mattered in the context of the technological competition with the Sovietviet union and so spider-man gets bitten by a radioactive spider right exactly i know i know this from so the fantastic are terribly successful and they're this scientific
他们总是……然而现在，几乎所有60年代的漫威英雄，科学虽然在某种程度上出了问题，但科学同时也是他们的朋友和武器。事实上，据称美国国务院曾对出版商说，我们希望你们推崇科学，我们希望你们拥抱科学，因为在与苏联的技术竞争背景下，这显然至关重要。所以蜘蛛侠被一只放射性蜘蛛咬了，对吧？完全正确。我知道这个……所以神奇四侠非常成功，他们是一个科学的……
and they're and they also bicker among themselves they're a sort of realist not realistic but you know what i mean they're slightly more naturalistic kind of family group. Now, Spider-Man takes Peter Parker, who would normally have been a sidekick by Robin, and it places him centre stage with no mentor. So he's a teenager. It's the first one where the teenager... But isn't his mentor... What's his name?
而且他们之间也会争吵，他们是一个某种程度上现实的——虽说不是绝对现实，但你知道我的意思——稍微更自然主义一点的家庭组合。现在，蜘蛛侠将本该扮演罗宾那种助手角色的彼得·帕克置于舞台中央，而且没有导师。所以他是个青少年。这是第一个青少年……但他的导师难道不是……他叫什么名字？
Uncle Ben. No. The guy who dresses up in metal. Iron Man. Iron Man. The guy who dresses up in metal. Iron Man. Iron Man. Dresses up in metal. It's like listening to my dad describing Star Wars. I know, I know, I know.
本叔叔。不是。那个穿金属衣服的人。钢铁侠。钢铁侠。那个穿金属衣服的人。钢铁侠。钢铁侠。穿着金属衣服。这就像听我爸爸描述《星球大战》一样。我懂，我懂，我懂。
Implausible. There are two metal men. Robert Downey Jr. Robert Downey Jr. He is in the films, but I don't think he is in the comic books. Is he not? At least not early on, in the first. But one of the interesting details I enjoyed reading in Grant Morrison's book was that Peter Parker apparently designed his Spider-Man outfit to look good on the Ed Sullivan show.
难以置信。有两个金属人。小罗伯特·唐尼。小罗伯特·唐尼。他出演了电影，但我觉得他不在漫画书里。不是吗？至少在早期第一部里没有。但我喜欢在格兰特·莫里森的书里读到的一个有趣细节是，彼得·帕克显然设计他的蜘蛛侠服装是为了在埃德·沙利文秀上看起来更好看。
Yeah. Which is what the Beatles then appeared on. Of course. So spiders, Beatles. So Peter Parker is very much rooted in the world of the 1960s. He's at high school. Later on, when he goes to university, some of his classmates are involved in demos and student protests and things.
是的。披头士乐队后来也登上了这个节目。当然。所以蜘蛛，披头士。因此彼得·帕克深深植根于20世纪60年代的世界。他在上高中。后来，当他上大学时，他的一些同学参与了示威、学生抗议等活动。
So that's why it matters that the other Tom Holland looks young. It has to look young. You can't have an older Tom Holland. But the other ones didn't, did they? They did. Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield. They were a tiny bit older. Tom Holland's probably the youngest.
所以这就是为什么另一个汤姆·霍兰德看起来年轻很重要。他必须看起来年轻。你不能找一个年纪大一点的汤姆·霍兰德。但其他的演员不是这样的，对吧？他们是。托比·马奎尔、安德鲁·加菲尔德。他们稍微大了一点点。汤姆·霍兰德可能年纪最小。
Tom Holland, I mean, you are Tom Holland. He's probably the youngest. And the most firmly rooted in that kind of high school stuff. And, of course, you know who says with great power comes with great responsibility, Tom? Spider-Man. No. Don't know. Nobody says it. Don't they?
汤姆·霍兰德——我的意思是，你就是汤姆·霍兰德。他可能年纪最小，并且最坚定地植根于那种高中生活的情境中。当然，你知道是谁说过“能力越大，责任越大”吗，汤姆？蜘蛛侠。不是。不知道。没有人说过。真的吗？
The line is actually, with great power. There must also come great responsibility. My son was very keen that I point this out on the podcast. Okay. And actually it's Stan Lee who says it. It's the narrator. Stan Lee, the head of Marvel comics, Stanley,
这句台词实际上是：“能力越大，责任也必然越大。”我儿子非常希望我在播客中指出这一点。好的。实际上是斯坦·李说的。是旁白说的。斯坦·李，漫威漫画的主编，斯坦·李说过，
just give them a lot of action and don't use too many words. Yeah. So they're quite kinetic. They're, they're sort of updated for the sixties. Okay. But convince me that this is of any interest at all from a historical point of view i mean it's all very interesting yes whatever but so what
给他们很多动作场面，别用太多词。是的。所以它们很有动感，为了60年代进行了某种更新。好吧，但请说服我，从历史的角度来看，这有任何价值吗？我的意思是，这一切都非常有趣，管他呢，那又怎样？
um i think it i think it's a huge part of american popular culture in the 1960s it obviously so what's it telling us about america what's it what's what's it revealing what's it what mirror is it showing up to the cultural neuroses of the age? I think what it is is that Spider-Man and Spider-Man and similar comics, they wrestle with kind of social issues of the 60s and later in the 70s. So, for example, there's a character called Green Lantern. In 1970, they have issues all about drugs, all about the war on drugs and so on and drug addiction and things.
嗯，我认为……我认为这是20世纪60年代美国流行文化中极其重要的一部分。这显然……那么它在向我们传递关于美国的什么信息？它在揭示什么？它反映了哪个时代的文化神经症？我认为是这样的：蜘蛛侠和类似的漫画，它们探讨了60年代以及后来70年代的各种社会问题。例如，有一个角色叫绿灯侠。在1970年，他们的故事完全围绕毒品、毒品战争以及药物成瘾等展开。
And you get Black Panther. Now, even you with your sort of… Wankada, is that right? Yeah. Wakonda. I think Wakonda. I don't think it's called Wankada. No, it's not.
你还会看到黑豹。现在，即使是你，以你那种……瓦坎达，是这样吗？是的。瓦坎达。我想是瓦坎达。我觉得它不叫“Wankada”。不，不是。
It can't be called Wankada. Even you with your imperviousness to the fear of cancellation, you're not going to slag off Black Panther because Black Panther… I don't know anything about it. I don't know anything about it. A sort of touchstone for diversity in Hollywood. People are very excited about Black Panther, but Black Panther was started in 1966
它不可能叫“Wankada”。即使是你，对于取消文化的恐惧有着极强的免疫力，你也不会去抨击《黑豹》，因为《黑豹》……我对它一无所知。我对它一无所知。它是好莱坞多元化的某种试金石。人们对《黑豹》感到非常兴奋，但《黑豹》诞生于1966年，
and he's the first kind of really successful black superhero. And which came first, the Black Panthers or Black Panther? That's a really good question. So were the Black Panthers naming themselves after a superhero? I don't know.
他是第一个真正成功的黑人超级英雄。那么，是黑豹党先出现，还是《黑豹》漫画先出现？这真是一个好问题。所以，黑豹党是以一个超级英雄的名字来命名自己的吗？我不知道。
Maybe listeners, people should go onto the Discord chat and tell us. No, I think you should look it up on Wikipedia right now. Right. Live research. Live research. Okay, fine. Because I'll be honest, if the Black Panthers named themselves after a comic book. Then it will matter.
也许听众朋友们可以去 Discord 聊天室告诉我们。不，我认为你现在就应该在维基百科上查一下。好。现场搜索。现场搜索。好吧，好吧。因为说实话，如果黑豹党是以一本漫画书来命名自己的……那这可就重要了。
Well, I'm going to think less of them. God, there's so much tension riding on this. Origins. But then if Black Panther is named after the Black Panthers, then that's kind of quite edgy. So they named themselves in October 1966. They adopt the Black Panther logo in their own organisation. Black uniforms and all that stuff.
好吧，我对他们的看法会降低。天哪，这上面承载了太多的悬念。起源。但如果《黑豹》是根据黑豹党命名的，那这就相当新潮前卫了。所以他们在1966年10月为自己命名。他们在自己的组织中采用了黑豹的标志。黑色的制服以及所有这些东西。
And when does the comic start? The tension, Tom. It's massive. This is so exciting. Have we done research live? Live research. July 1966, Black Panther comes first. The character.
那漫画是什么时候开始的？这种悬念，汤姆。太巨大了。这太令人兴奋了。我们做过现场研究吗？现场研究。1966年7月，《黑豹》先出现。这个角色。
Then I think, well. So I've been utterly vindicated. Tom now recognises that comic books do matter enormously. Yes, I do. Yeah. I don't know whether they knew of the comic, though. Were they reading the comics? It seems a bit of a coincidence.
那我想，好吧。所以我完全被平反了。汤姆现在承认漫画书确实非常重要。是的，我承认。是的。不过我不知道他们是否知道这部漫画。他们当时在读这些漫画吗？这似乎有点巧合。
Yeah. Well, anyway, Black Panther now really matters. I mean, Black Panther is seen as probably more than anything that Hollywood has done in the last 10 or 20 years. As an embodiment of its newfound kind of progressiveness. So when the Black Panther film came out, it was nominated for Oscars and stuff, and it's absolutely seen as emblematic
嗯，无论如何，《黑豹》现在确实非常重要。我的意思是，《黑豹》被视为好莱坞在过去10到20年里做过的所有事情中最重要的一部。它是好莱坞新发现的某种进步主义的化身。所以当《黑豹》电影上映时，它获得了奥斯卡等奖项的提名，并且绝对被视为一种全新的多族裔流行文化的象征。所以你看。而且，汤姆，事实上，说到将漫画书和超级英雄作为一面镜子，它们绝对是一面镜子。因为在30年代和40年代，你有超人。我知道它们是。我刚才就是这么说的。我正试图把你拉回正轨。
of a kind of new multiracial kind of popular culture. So there you go. And also, Tom, actually, talking about comic books and superheroes as a mirror, they absolutely are a mirror. Because in the 30s and 40s, you have Superman. I know they are. That's what I was saying. I was trying to get you back on track.
你有超人类型的英雄。在60年代，你有青少年。然后在70年代，他们开始内省，许多角色开始被写死。然后在80年代，你迎来了全新的一波浪潮——那么提姆·波顿的提姆·波顿电影？不，在这之前，在这之前，在这之前。那么80年代发生了什么？有一个叫弗兰克·米勒的人，你肯定认识他，因为哦，我确实认识弗兰克·米勒，是的——所以《蝙蝠侠：黑暗骑士归来》，《黑暗骑士归来》，现在你有了年长一些的蝙蝠侠，它要激进得多，它要——我的意思是，弗兰克·米勒有点像个自由意志主义者，对吧？
You have Superman-type heroes. In the 60s, you have teenagers. Then in the 70s, they turn inwards, and a lot of characters start getting killed off. And then in the 80s, you have this whole new kind of wave so so Tim Burton the Tim Burton film no before that before that before that so what's happening in the 80s so there's a guy called Frank Miller who you will know because of oh I do know Frank Miller yes so the Dark Knight Returns the Dark Knight Returns and now you have an older Batman it's much more aggressive it is much I mean Frank Miller is kind of a libertarian, isn't he?
非常保守。它要暴力得多，令人难以置信的暴力。《黑暗骑士归来》——你一定喜欢这个——是一个罗纳德·里根大约120岁的美国。对，没错，里根担任总统。同样的事情也发生在
Very conservative. It's much more incredibly violent. And The Dark Knight Returns, and you must like this, is an America where Reagan is about 120. Yes, exactly, where Reagan is president. And the same thing in
《守望者》中——我确信我们一会儿就会谈到——尼克松仍然在位。是的。所以有一种奇怪的事情正在发生，一种奇怪的事情正在发生，那就是共和党总统从不退休。那么那里到底发生了什么？是的，这是漫画作家的一种偏执想象。漫画作家往往不是那种……你知道的，某种中间派。
Watchmen, which I'm sure we'll come to in a minute, where Nixon is still in power. Yes. So there's a kind of weird thing going on, weird thing going on where Republican presidents never retire. So what's going on there? Yeah, it's a sort of paranoid imagination of comic book writers. Comic book writers tend not to be, you know, sort of centrists.
稳扎稳打的建制派中间派。他们往往倾向于意识形态上的左翼或右翼边缘。弗兰克·米勒是一端，阿兰·摩尔——伟大的英国漫画作家——他是英国人，因为相当一部分这种对美国标准的先锋重塑实际上都来自英国的艺术学校。没错，绝对如此。所以阿兰·摩尔，来自北安普顿，他写了一部绝对经典的漫画书叫做《守望者》，被《时代》杂志列为20世纪100本最佳图书之一。我看过这部电影。
Steady as she goes, establishment centrists. They tend to be on the kind of i you would say the ideological fringes of the left or right frank miller on one side alan moore the great british comic writer he's british because quite a lot of these kind of edgy reworkings of american standards have kind of they're coming from british art schools right absolutely absolutely so alan moore who's from northampton he writes this absolutely classic comic book called Watchmen, listed by Time magazine as one of the 100 best books of the 20th century. I've seen the film.
我完全不知道发生了什么。如果你喜欢漫画书的话，这部漫画绝对棒极了。事实上，两年前出了一部电视剧，获得了无数的艾美奖，绝对精彩绝伦。所以这部漫画基本上是在探讨：如果超级英雄是真实的会怎样？如果他们一直活下来会怎样？他们帮助美国赢得了越南战争。是的。
I had no idea what was going on. The comic book is absolutely fantastic if you like comic books. And actually, there's a TV series that came out two years ago that won tons and tons of Emmys and was absolutely brilliant. So the comic book is basically saying, slightly what if superheroes were real and what if they had carried on living? And they helped America to win the Vietnam War. Yeah.
戴着面具当义务警员会是什么感觉，也许有超能力，也许没有？事实上，它还涉及到一个点，因为它里面有一个超级英雄，基本上变成了神。他去火星上生活了。他拥有生命和神的力量。他去火星上生活了。他拥有生与死的力量。他可以某种程度上重塑现实。但它不如《海扁王》好看。
What would it be like to be a costumed vigilante, maybe with or without powers? And actually it also picks up because it has a superhero who basically becomes God. He goes and lives on Mars. He has the power of life and God. He goes and lives on Mars. He has the power of life and death. He can kind of remake reality. But it's not as good as Kick-Ass.
我没看过《海扁王》。《海扁王》很棒。《海扁王》讲的是一个打扮成超级英雄的漫画迷的故事。但《守望者》电视剧所做的，我认为非常有趣，而且也是一面非常好的镜子。那部剧大约两年前播出了，它将《守望者》的故事推向了一个新的高度，因为它部分地以1921年塔尔萨种族大屠杀为背景——这个伟大而可怕的时刻——哦，那是某种空中袭击，对吧？
I haven't seen Kick-Ass. Kick-Ass is great. Kick-Ass is about a comic book fan who dresses up as a superhero. But then what the TV series Watchmen does, which I think is really interesting, and again a very good mirror. So that came out about two years ago and that took the watchmen story a level further because it's it set it against the backdrop partly of the tulsa race massacre in 1921 this great sort of terrible moment well they kind of aerial attack isn't it
据称对塔尔萨的一个黑人聚居区发动了空中袭击，当时那里是美国最繁荣的黑人城市。而且……《守望者》电视剧所做的，是指出了两者的某种相似性——我的意思是，蒙面义务警员，三K党不就是蒙面义务警员吗？对吧……所以我是对的——所以这是一个右翼的幻想吗？好吧，我的意思是，那部剧所玩味的就是：他们是站在穷人和正义这一边，还是诸如此类？还是说他们有点像法西斯主义者，这也是你在克里斯托弗·诺兰的蝙蝠侠电影中看到的。是的。
supposedly aerial attacks on a black quarter of tulsa then the most thriving black city in america and um and what the watchman tv series does is it points out the sort of similarity i mean masked vigilantes that's what the ku klux klan are they're masked vigilantes right um so i'm right so it is a right-wing fantasy well i mean that is what the that series kind of plays with is that are they on the side of the poor and of justice and all that sort of stuff? Or are they kind of fascistic, which is also what you see in the Christopher Nolan Batman films. Yeah.
蝙蝠侠这个角色。所以在克里斯托弗·诺兰蝙蝠侠电影的最后一部——《蝙蝠侠：黑暗骑士崛起》，我想。那是带有希斯·莱杰的那部吗？不，那是中间那部。所以那是带有汤姆·哈迪的那部。哦，就是那个你完全听不清他在说什么的角色。戴着面具。
The Batman figure. So in the final film of the Christopher Nolan Batman films, The Dark Knight Rises, I think. That's the one with Heath Ledger. No, that's the middle one. So it's the one with Tom Hardy. Oh, where you can't hear a word he says. From his mask.
对。我是哥谭的复仇。所有这些类似的东西。所以在电影中，有《双城记》的引言之类的东西。贝恩在哥谭引发了一场革命。而蝙蝠侠基本上是在为秩序力量、建制派、富人而战。因为他自己当然也是个富豪。
Yes. I am Gotham's reckoning. All that kind of stuff. So in that film, there are sort of Tale of Two Cities quotations and stuff like that. There's a revolution in Gotham that Bane causes. And Batman is basically fighting on behalf of the forces of order, the establishment, the rich. Because he's rich, of course, himself.
那就是布鲁斯·韦恩。所以这在某种程度上是在拿它的政治属性开玩笑，但我认为真正有趣的是——我想我们以前和邦德讨论过这个问题——在21世纪，你根本无法再拍摄那种不带反讽、不带自我意识、纯粹英雄主义的超级英雄电影了。他们必须内心纠结。必须有一个创伤性的背景故事。
That's Bruce Wayne. So that's sort of having some fun, I think, with the politics of it. But actually, what's really interesting is that, I think we've talked about this before with Bond, how in the 21st century, you just can't do unironic, un-self-conscious, heroic superheroes anymore. They have to be conflicted. There has to be a traumatic backstory.
好吧，那么我们认为这是为什么呢？嗯，我想因为显然其中一个干预因素是——我们这里有一个山姆·伯罗斯提出的问题：在9·11、经济衰退和流行病之后，你认为当前对超级英雄的痴迷实际上是怀旧的产物，是对一个
Okay, so why is that, do we think? Well, I think because obviously one of the things that intervene, so we've got a question here from Sam Burrows. In the wake of 9-11, recessions and pandemics, do you think the current obsession with superheroes is actually a product of nostalgia, a longing for a time
事情感觉美好的时代的渴望吗？据推测，如果你说现在不可能再有不带反讽的超级英雄了，事实并非如此。我不知道。漫威电影是怀旧吗？我不知道，因为它们吸引的
in which things felt good? Presumably, if you're saying it's impossible to have ironic, unironic superheroes anymore, that's not the case. I don't know. Are the Marvel films nostalgia? I don't know because they're appealing
是比我们年轻的人。那他们在怀旧什么呢？我儿子几天后就10岁了，他和他的朋友们都喜欢漫威电影，但他们喜欢它们并不是出于怀旧。我的意思是，我对怀旧毫无兴趣。我看的X战警电影——因为我女儿曾经短暂地非常迷恋它们——
to people who are younger than us. So what are they nostalgic for? My son who is 10 in a few days, he and his friends all love the Marvel films but they don't like them out of nostalgia. I mean they have no interest in me nostalgia. The X-Men films that I saw because my daughter got very into them briefly
故事是围绕猪湾事件展开的。抱歉，是古巴导弹危机。然后还有一部是关于试图阻止越南战争的。所以那可能确实带有怀旧色彩。非常植根于……而且其中涉及金刚狼回到过去。你看，我认为人们普遍在从英雄主义退缩，对吧？
were based around the Bay of Pigs episode. Sorry, the Cuban Missile Crisis. And then there was one about an attempt to stop the Vietnam War. So that probably was nostalgic. Very rooted in, and it involved Wolverine going back in time. See, I think there's a general retreat from heroism, isn't there?
如果你要为 UnHerd 写一篇关于这方面的文章，我可能会……哦，违背乌合之众的心态。没错。我可能会说这是一种对西方的信仰丧失。我的意思是，这会不会太……好吧，我同意，因为你在西部片中也看到了同样的情况，在我看来，西部片与此非常相似。是的。
And if you were writing an essay about it for UnHerd, I would sort of... Oh, going against the herd mentality. Exactly. I might well say that it was a sort of loss of faith in the West. I mean, is that too... Well, I agree because you see the same thing with Westerns, which seem to me very analogous. Yeah.
那是关于好人清除坏人、整顿秩序的故事。但你现在拍不出一部不带反讽的西部片了。不，我的意思是，在所有这些作品中——你谈到了……黑豹——难道这不也与人们对白人特权的焦虑捆绑在一起吗？我想布鲁斯·韦恩就会是这种焦虑的绝对化身。所以我感到很有趣，因为有一部罗伯特·帕丁森版本的蝙蝠侠即将上映，从预告片来看，它显得非常黑暗。实际上，这正是自《黑暗骑士归来》、弗兰克·米勒的作品以来的趋势，
That it's about good guys cleaning up, sorting out the baddies. But you can't have an unironic western now no i mean in all these and you've talked about um uh black panther i mean is it not also tied up with uh anxieties about white privilege of whom i guess bruce wayne would bruce wayne would be the absolute embodiment so i'm interesting because there's a robert patterson version of batman that's coming out that looks very, from the trailer, look incredibly dark. And actually that's been the trend
使得蝙蝠侠越来越像一个反派。我的意思是，你会看到那种几乎每次都会出现的场景，你在上一部邦德电影里看过，你在现在的一切作品里都能看到：“我们其实没什么不同，你和我。”你知道，反派对英雄说的话。然后你会觉得：“哦，这太有深度了。”
since the Dark Knight returns, Frank Miller stuff, so that Batman becomes more and more of a villain. I mean, there's that scene that you almost always get, you got it in the last Bond film, you get it in everything now. We're not so different, you and I. You know, the villain talking to the hero. And you're like, oh, that's very profound.
他们是同一枚硬币的两面。但你看到了这种现象。看到亚当·韦斯特风格的电影不是很好吗？砰！啪！是的。然后英雄说：“实际上，我们非常不同。你是个反派。”
They're two sides of the same coin. But you see that. Wouldn't it be great to see, you know, the Adam West style? Pow! Zam! Yeah. And the hero saying, actually, we're very different. You're a villain.
“我要把你带走。没错。戈登局长，给他戴上手铐。”是的。是的。我认为这会有市场的。好吧，我想这可能就是未来的发展方向，不是吗？我要把你带走，没错，戈登局长，给他戴上手铐，是的，是的，我想这会有市场的。好吧，我想这可能
I'm taking you in. Exactly. Commissioner Gordon, cuff him. Yeah. Yeah. I think there'd be a market for that. Well, I think that's probably the way to go, isn't it? I'm taking you in exactly Commissioner Gordon cuff him yeah yeah I think there'll be a market for that well I think that's
就是未来的发展方向，不是吗？当我建立我的工作室时，我就会这么做。将会出现某种代际反弹，并且会有一个
probably the way to go isn't it when I set up my studio that's what I'll do there will be some sort of generational backlash and there'll be a
就像70年代《星球大战》的诞生以及对善恶之间更清晰界限的需求一样，你不觉得那终究会到来吗？
as there was in the 70s with the creation of Star Wars and the demand for kind of a clearer line between good and evil don't you think that'll come eventually
难道我们要永远沉浸在某种虚无主义中吗？还是说不用？我不知道。虚无主义侠。是的，这就是你的超能力。虚无主义侠。实际上有多个人向我们问过这个问题。
we'd have to say stay immersed in kind of cynicism forever. Or do we? I don't know. Cynicism man. Yeah, that's your power. Cynicism man. Multiple people actually have asked us this question.
我们最适合哪个超级英雄？比如斯蒂芬·克拉克。所以，汤姆，如果你是一个超级英雄，你会是谁？我可能会是执事。你会是执事？或者也许，比如说。所以，汤姆，如果你是一个超级英雄，你会是谁？我可能会是执事。你会是执事？或者也许是体育大师。是的，因为你在打板球。我是一根板球拍。我只会投掷。
Which superhero do we suit best? Stephen Clarke, for example. So Tom, if you were a superhero, who would you be? I'd probably be the deacon. You'd be the deacon? Or maybe, for example. So, Tom, if you were a superhero, who would you be? I'd probably be the deacon. You'd be the deacon? Or maybe the sportsmaster. Yeah, because you're cricketing. I'm a cricket bat. I just hurl.
你觉得我会是谁？我觉得你会……你会是无敌浩克吗？对，我确实花了很多时间在生气上。而且我被激怒时真的会变绿。所以也许我会接受这个。不，我想，我想——显然我会是雷神。你会吗？肌肉发达，长相英俊，你很擅长用锤子。我很想模仿安东尼·霍普金斯把你逐出阿斯加德的语气，但我不会这么做。
Who do you think I would be? I think you'd be... Would you be the Incredible Hulk? Yeah, I do spend a lot of time getting angry. And I do go green when roused. So maybe i'll take it yeah no i think i think i mean obviously i'd be thor would you why brawny good looking you're great with a hammer i i'm tempted to do my impersonation of anthony hopkins throwing you out of hasgard, but I won't.
我完全不知道你在说什么。不，你不知道。好了。我有没有让你相信超级英雄很重要、它们在历史上很有趣？好吧。我的意思是，是的，直到你在60年代有点偏离正轨。
I have no idea what you're talking about. No, you don't. Right. Have I convinced you that superheroes matter, that they're historically interesting? Yeah. I mean, I think so, until you slightly went off-piste in the 60s.
而且我不认为它们现在真的很重要。好吧，那可不是偏离正轨。我认为它们的涌现、早期的那些内容，我认为那很有趣。是的。你不觉得60年代的内容很有趣吗？不觉得特别有趣，不。太让人震惊了。不，我不觉得。
And I don't think they really matter now. Well, that wasn't off-piste. I think their emergence, the early stuff, I think that's interesting. Yeah. You don't think the 60s stuff is interesting? Not particularly, no. Shocking. No, I don't.
我认为当人们……我们做过一整期关于青少年的节目，而彼得·帕克除了是个青少年之外什么都不是。他就是一个来自那种……是的，但那又怎样？我的意思是，这就像猴子乐队。我们会做一期关于猴子乐队的节目吗？我的意思是，这基本上就是猴子乐队，对吧？我想确实有点像，但我的意思是，我们做过一期关于烧杯的节目。我意思是，这基本上就是猴子乐队，对吧？我想确实有点像。但我的意思是，我们做过一期关于烧杯的节目。
I think when people... We did a whole episode about teenagers, and Peter Parker is nothing if not a teenager. He's a teenager from the kind of... Yeah, but say what? I mean, it's like the monkeys. Would we do an episode on the monkeys? I mean, it's basically the monkeys, isn't it? I suppose it is a bit, but I mean, we did an episode on the beakers I mean, it's basically the monkeys, isn't it? I suppose it is a bit. But I mean, we did an episode on beakers.
这就好像是穿着奇怪服装的猴子乐队。好吧。不过还有一个最后的问题，那就是，我认为我对整个这件事产生相当积极的敌意的另一个原因。是的。就是我觉得被霸凌了。因为有人在推特上祝你生日快乐。
It's the monkeys in a kind of weird suit. Yeah. All right. Well. But one final question, which is, I think another reason why I'm quite actively hostile to the whole thing. Yeah. Is that I feel bullied by. People wishing you a happy birthday on Twitter.
就像穿着奇怪制服的猴子。是的。好吧。不过还有一个最后的问题，这也是为什么我对整件事感到相当敌视的另一个原因。那就是我觉得在推特上被那些祝你生日快乐的人给霸凌了。
No, it's not that. Under the impression that you're 17. I feel bullied by the kind of juggernaut quality of this essentially special effects driven... I mean, the ones that I've seen...
不，不是那样的。给我的印象是觉得你才17岁。我觉得自己被这种基本上由特效驱动的巨无霸性质的东西给欺负了……我的意思是，我看到的那些……
I'm with Ridley Scott and... Martin Scorsese. Martin Scorsese. I think they're stupid and dumb and pointless. I think that's too harsh. I think they are. But I'm aware, but I'm 53. They're not in you, yeah.
我和雷德利·斯科特以及……马丁·斯科塞斯是一伙的。马丁·斯科塞斯。我觉得它们又蠢又笨又毫无意义。我觉得这话有点太重了。我觉得就是这样。但我有自知之明，不过我都53岁了。它们没有融入你的生命，是的。
And I was never interested in the first place. So I'd be interested in your view on, I mean, they do seem to me expressive of a kind of new era of American cultural supremacy. So they seem to me the cinematic equivalent of the dominance of Google and Apple and these vast, colossal edifices before which everyone else are just kind of tiny little ants, spiders, dare I say. I think there's a lot of truth in that.
而且我一开始就没兴趣。所以我很想听听你的看法，我是说，它们在我看来确实表达了一种美国文化霸权的新时代。所以它们在我看来，就像是谷歌、苹果以及那些庞大无比的巨型建筑的电影版，在这些巨物面前，其他人不过是微不足道的小蚂蚁、蜘蛛，我甚至敢这么说。我觉得这里面有很大的道理。
I think they have sucked. I think they're extremely well made and they're very effective. I've actually never seen one without falling asleep because I find the narrative so formulaic that I actually find them quite boring. But I can't help noticing that all the nine and ten year olds, particularly boys
我觉得它们一直都很烂。我认为它们制作极其精良，效果也非常震撼。其实我每次看都会睡着，因为我发现它们的叙事太套路化了，以至于我甚至觉得它们非常无聊。但我忍不住注意到，所有的九岁和十岁儿童，尤其是男孩们
are my acquaintance. I love them. The one thing I will say is I think the air is seeping out of that balloon because I think their box office returns have been dwindling a little bit in the last couple of years. Trounced by James Bond, I gather. Yeah, well, I mean, yeah. Although it'd be interesting to see how Spider-Man does.
我认识的那些。我太爱他们了。我要说的一点是，我觉得那个气球正在漏气，因为我认为它们在过去几年的票房收入有点在萎缩。我听说被詹姆斯·邦德打败了。是的，好吧，我是说，是的。虽然蜘蛛侠的表现会怎样，这倒挺让人感兴趣的。
I hate my name. Are you going to go and see it? I'm not, no. So Tom Holland is doing something else now, which is gutting for you, isn't he? He's doing Fred Astaire. He's a great dancer. You must have seen him
我讨厌我的名字。你会去看吗？我不会，不看。所以汤姆·霍兰德现在在做别的事了，这对你来说很心碎吧？他正在演弗雷德·阿斯泰尔。他是个伟大的舞者。你一定看过他
do the famous thing where he is Fred Astaire and then he turns into Rihanna. You must have seen that. No, what is that? Oh, it's brilliant. It's how he announced himself when he got named as Spider-Man before the first Spider-Man film came out he went on this kind of dance-a-thon where you have to you know dance to well-known music yeah he first he comes on and he's fred astaire and he's got the umbrella and uh it's raining and then he goes off and he comes back
表演那个著名的节目，他先是扮演弗雷德·阿斯泰尔，然后变成了蕾哈娜。你一定看过那个。不，那是什么？哦，太精彩了。那是他刚被宣布成为蜘蛛侠时宣告自己到来的一种方式，在第一部蜘蛛侠电影上映之前，他参加了一个类似于马拉松的舞蹈活动，你得伴着著名的音乐跳舞。对，他先是上场，扮成弗雷德·阿斯泰尔，拿着雨伞，呃，外面下着雨，然后他下台了，又上来了
on he's dressed as rihanna and he does um umbrella it's absolutely brilliant if you haven on, he's dressed as Rihanna, and he does Umbrella. It's absolutely brilliant, if you haven't seen it. He's dressed as Rihanna? Yeah. Isn't that quite risky now? I mean, cultural appropriation and all that kind of stuff. No, he's non-binary. Is he? He's not.
上台时，他打扮成蕾哈娜的样子，跳了《Umbrella》。如果你没看过，真的是绝了。他打扮成蕾哈娜？对。现在这样难道不是很冒险吗？我是说，文化挪用之类的事情。不，他是非二元性别的。是吗？他不是。
You've made that up. He's two spirits. Well, it's... Two spirits. He's making play with gender stereotypes. Is he? Right. You heard it here first from Tom Holland himself.
你是编出来的吧。他是双灵人。好吧，这……双灵人。他在玩弄性别刻板印象。是吗？对。这就是你从汤姆·霍兰德本人那里听到的第一手消息。
That's what it's all about. And on that bombshell. He's obviously paying homage to Madame Fatale. Of course he was. The retired actor who fights crime disguised as an old lady. It's goodbye from me, the Incredible Hulk, and it's goodbye from him, the sportsman, and we will see you next time.
事情就是这样。带着这个爆炸性的消息。他显然是在向法塔勒夫人致敬。他当然是。那个伪装成老太太打击犯罪的退休演员。我是无敌浩克，由我向大家道别，另一位是那位运动员，由他向大家道别，我们下期再见。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。